okay
all right okay
uh good morning as chair of the house
edna committee i find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule
67 and governor's emergency order 12
first one to executive order 202004
this public body namely the edna
committee is authorized to meet
electronically this is a committee
orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however
in accordance with the emergency order i
am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been available in the
house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa
91 a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271 3600 or email
hcs leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
accept access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled and
i want to introduce pam smarling for
house committee research
who is here on the meeting to assist us
she is also our committee researcher
for the rest of the rest of the session
please note that all votes taken during
this meeting will be done by a roll call
vote
we will start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
and when each member states their
present please also state
where you are whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
representative scitec if you would call
the role
hmm
okay
thank you
uh
representative
[Music]
i'm here alone in my truck
i can't either it's the same
john could you let pam call the role
you're being you're extremely despondent
i i'd be happy to take over i'm sorry
representative scitec here yeah your
sound
i'm here alone in the room at home
so should i begin
i don't even know if you can hear us
yeah i don't think he hears us
either yes
um it may be that the only way to signal
him
that he can't hear us is to mute him and
when he doesn't get any responses he'll
know
okay so i will mute him and see what he
happened says say
still trying don't
so would you like me to uh resume with
the roll call
you should probably start over pam yes
yes all right representative scitec i
hope you're you're hearing this
i don't i i keep hearing
something from him even though he's
muted which is yes which is bizarre
it is bizarre thank you but it's not
just me that would really make me worry
all right i'll i'll go through the roll
call from the top
um representative mcguire yes i'm in uh
yes i'm hearing things from
representative scitec also
but i'm in the lob cyber room
i'm alone representative roy
i am here i am in my truck alone driving
through bear brook state park
representative scitec maybe
all right
okay we we hear you very in a very
distorted way so i did
hear that but it's it's not clear
representative pearson
i am here located in derry
here at home
i keep getting muted automatically
no it's me muting you because uh even
though you're muted
something is coming through
is it possible
[Music]
hopefully he'll connect by phone and
then that would just be
a clearer sound all around
representative yakubovic
here alone in the room at home thank you
representative lekkas i'm
here at home in my home in hudson uh
currently alone it's possible that at
some point representative alicia leckus
might walk through
all right representative allegro
um allegro and allegro that's okay
the i fouls everybody up i'm here
alone in my home office enjoying the
wonders of modern technology
representative bailey
i'm here alone in milton
thank you uh representative lonzara
i'm here and i do have some kids on zoom
in the other
in the other rooms in the house and
things like that i mean
all right representative santo nostal
i don't see
representative goalie
i'm here uh home
and my wife will be in and out of the
room at times
representative schuett
at home and alone except for my cat
representative judy is not here
representative schmidt i am
present at my home in dover and i am
alone
representative schultz
i am present and conquered my husband
will be in and out of the room
as will my cat and my dog representative
fellows
come alone representative fontenot
i am present i am home in rochester
and my wife is also in the building
um representative grota
i'm in my home and my office alone
and finally representative o'brien
i am present uh i am at home and i
am alone with an occasional grandkid
buzzing through
okay so it appears we have a quorum
i've been trying to call representative
scitec but he doesn't answer
um he's looking at his phone
all right let's try again see if i can
connect
but anyway this is our
first meeting for edna this year
and
wanted to have us introduce ourselves
and also to let you know what we'll be
doing this year
so far the uh
uh the speaker has not yet decided
that what we'll be doing
hi john well that's that's his voice man
um so i'm trying to schedule
a public hearing for next week next week
it will be entirely remote they won't
let people into the building
and um so
that'll be a challenge to do it properly
later on i believe we will have hybrid
meetings
so if anyone exp i would expect that as
many people as possible
should be attending um when we get set
up
if you will not be attending under any
circumstances
let me know online um
it's your decision of course
so anyway edna is a generally a fairly
busy committee this is my third term
as a uh as chair of edna
we have currently 45 bills
i expect another 20 to 40 by the time
we're finished
and they're generally in four
different areas the state retirement
system
which affects localities as well because
it covers
state employees firemen
police corrections officers and teachers
throughout the state and some local
employees as well
we have professional licensing which is
uh we'll be getting a brief orientation
on that this afternoon
the organization of the state government
itself
so we've got bills on department of
information technology
and on the governor's executive powers
both
so we will be covering a lot of that
and what's the fourth area oh
administrative rules
we'll have a brief introduction to that
tomorrow afternoon
and we'll be glad to answer questions
this committee supplies uh most members
of
the joint legislative committee on
administrative rules
and i believe that the staff will be
inquiring if you're interested
in the near future because we're short
of uh of
alternates for the house and i'll start
the introduction by saying that
i'm in my seventh term i live in epsom
and i'm i'm a retired aerospace engineer
and let's see
mr representative allegro let's go in
alphabetical order
oh you want a brief introduction to me
is that it yes please
um i'm a uh retired scientist a cellular
molecular biologist i live in
campton and um don't know what to add to
that
at the moment
you're muted carol
i hope okay there you go representative
bailey
i'm uh i work as a reviewer for an
online
college review student projects um
i live in milton what was that what else
did you want to know
uh anything else that you think is of
importance to us
i guess that's about it okay
okay fellows
morning this is my second term in
the legislature and last year i was also
on edna
my background is in education most of
that time was at the department of
education
and my expertise is school data school
funding
grants that sort of thing
okay represent font now
good morning uh tim fontenot from
rochester
um this is my third term in the
legislature
second on uh edna i
am also a full-time uh realtor
and uh real estate investor
um and um
[Music]
also a full-time landlord so i have a
few a few hats
a few jobs that i wear i'm glad you can
squeeze this in
thanks
representative goalie
good morning i'm uh currently serving my
11th term in the house
um first five terms were on the labor
committee
um two of which i chaired and then uh
the past
few terms i've been on edna and i am the
past chair
at on edna i'm just currently retired in
november from the manchester fire
department as a captain
uh served there for 32 and a half years
and glad to be back on edna
okay represent baroda good morning i'm
jackie grota i live in ryde this is my
second term and my second term serving
on edna
i am a retired chemical engineer
and i serve currently on in my town
on the conservation commission and i
chair the budget committee
okay represent judy isn't here
representative lanzara
hi uh windsor born and raised in nashua
i'm a nashua full-time fireman um
a couple degrees from the university of
new haven one is arts and investigations
um and my father was a state rep back in
the 80s so
kind of carrying on this uh this would
be my first term
but carrying on the family tradition and
trying to help new hampshire
okay president lincus
hello everyone um this is my second term
in the legislature last year i was on a
muslim county government committee um
in my background i've worked for over 40
years as a
computer and electrical engineer i was
able to retire
a little over a year ago and i'm down
here in hudson new hampshire where we
blew for i think over 36 years now so
i think that's it good representative
pearson
i am representative pearson i am a
long-time resident
of derry i my background is i have a
engineering degree in fire protection
and a master's degree in public
administration from oklahoma state
i currently serve as a lieutenant on the
manchester fire department
along with other governmental things
that i am involved
in and i'm happy to be returning to edna
for my second time
okay representative roy
hello um i'm representative roy i
am from deerfield i represent candia
deerfield nottingham in northwood
this is my second term in the house
i started off in the dna i went to
criminal justice
i missed peter schmidt so much that i
requested to be sent back
to edna and i'm back here again um and
i'm happy to be back with you guys it
was fun the first time
um let me see i am retired law
enforcement i have a bachelor's degree
in criminal justice
i'm a 100 disabled veteran i have some
spinal issues i got
courtesy of the army um
i am on my municipal budget committee
and other than that i'm an avid
outdoorsman
i love hunting and
that's about it
see here i see somebody label
unnamed becky benvenuti
does anybody know who that might be
i'm matt was in the um
as a participant he's rejoining as a
panelist
there he is all right great
so i'm not sure who becky benvenuti is
but if you could
identify yourself i don't know how you
got here
hi um this is becky benvenuti i
joined using the public link
and i am with the new hampshire
municipal association but i would be
glad to leave the meeting and
rejoin um using that link again if if
that would be appropriate
um it i was i was not connected and then
suddenly
it the link went out and it i came back
in and was
connected so i'm not sure what happened
but
i'm not sure what happened either but i
don't have the option to return you to
the attendee
list so if you would if you wouldn't
mind signing off and coming back in that
way that would be
that would be helpful thank you i would
be very happy to do that
thank you uh hello
yes representative sanchez castle yeah
hey how you doing my first time in the
house uh
moved to new hampshire because i think
it's the
greatest state in the union i just want
to do my part to
keep it that way
okay
all right representative schmidt
good morning everyone my name is peter
schmidt
i'm starting my 15th year on
edna i previously served
a year on ena environment and
agriculture for the newbies
and three years before that on the
municipal and county government
committee so
i am have a similar um
trajectory if you will as representative
leakas
coming over from another committee
i am in my 19th year in the legislature
um i uh represent wards one and two in
dover
um and in the house i serve
also on the assessing standards board
for about 15 years now i'm also
on the joint committee on employee
classification
i've served on that for about 10 years
along with
representative scitec i'm also
on the vital records privacy board
uh as the as the
secretary of uh state's designee
and my background is in foreign
languages
in terms of my university degrees
and i'm delighted to have representative
roy back because
i always need somebody that um
can give me a certain sense of security
in case we have a
disturbance because terry is big enough
to intimidate just about anybody who's
not playing
defensive line in the nfl
thank you representative schmidt that's
uh representative schuett
thank you um i'll just point out that uh
going alphabetically we seem to have
skipped representative o'brien i don't
want him to feel left out
um you're so right i'm having a little
difficulty with the alphabet this
morning
my fault that's okay i think he would
have come right after you so
and you went first so uh anyway my name
is diane
schuett i represent chichester pembroke
and this is my fifth term in the
legislature
although previously i put in
25 years and retired after working in
the house clerk's office so i'm very
familiar with the buildings
and the process i've
this is my i believe my fourth term
on edna i've served two terms as
vice chair i've also served on municipal
and county government
labor and legislative administration
and i'm not sure i get
still on the joint committee on
administrative rules i have not received
an official appointment notice but
they keep notifying me so i guess still
on that
you were you're listed on the sign in
sheet as an
alternate but if you haven't got an
appointment letter you should
tell the speaker yeah
but we want you thanks
skipping back to representative o'brien
uh thank you good morning everybody and
i don't mind being skipped uh
patience is a virtue so no problem uh
i'm michael o'brien
uh i'm retired uh my occupation was uh
i worked as a firefighter for the city
of nashua
and i retired with the rank of uh deputy
fire chief
uh my experience in the house i think
this is my eighth
or ninth term i gotta do the math on
that
but i had the honor of uh being uh most
of my career with the state was on the
transportation committee
where i had the honor to serve three
times as a
vice chair of transportation i'm
currently now
a member also of the city of nashua
board of aldermen
and i currently also serve as vice
president of the board
i'm on the committees of uh chairman of
infrastructure
i'm on the budget finance and the
pentatruck water committee so
uh it keeps me busy
that's for sure all right representative
schultz
hi this is my fourth year as a state rep
i came in from a special election
i love our committee we get so many
interesting bills
uh and i've enjoyed serving with
everybody
and look forward to serving with the new
folks i'm
currently furloughed from my job with
the new hampshire
bible society so i'm actually looking
for
more remote work on communications and
outreach for non-profits before that
i was a democratic operative and served
for some years for a variety of
congressmen
on capitol hill so i'm
glad to be with you guys
okay representative scitec can we hear
him
um
are you distorted
have you dialed in it looks like your
phone
it looks like your phone representative
sites but
you can't hear the phone and stuff it's
my
thought
i i can allow you to talk through your
phone if you want to try that
i have to shut the phone off
you have to hit star six
you're now your phone is muted currently
my name
[Applause]
between your phone and your computer
[Music]
i'm out
away from your computer step away from
your computer
hi everyone i've left the meeting uh my
next stop is the computer
store to get uh try to get a
camera a good camera instead of this
uh lenovo thing that i'm on uh jeff you
actually retired
when did 32 years have you been when did
you start when you were eight years old
no that's amazing you didn't invite me
to the party either
all right i'm john scitec i represent
salem barely new hampshire
um i was in for three terms in the 90s
this is
starting my sixth term now i'm starting
to get the hang of all this
uh i've all my times been on edna which
is a wonderful committee you see
everything
uh i am actually i'm a semi-retired
mostly retired school teacher i gave a
test this morning the kids suck i got to
give a retest
it was terrible i uh
i'm a bail commissioner i uh uh
on jcec along with representative
schmidt
i am a town treasurer in salem i like to
collect minor offices
and uh that's who i am
oh i'm a retire as i said mostly retired
school teacher that's
i had an engineering background which i
occasionally use
thank you and if we're ever in need of a
witty comment
john supplies it okay
representative i'm michael jacobs from
hooksett
uh second term glad to be back on the
committee
computer engineer by trade
excellent um this is going to be a very
strange year
because as i said we will be working
remotely for at least the next couple of
weeks
i hope we will be able to get at least
into a hybrid situation
but i haven't seen it um
and most most of my comments would only
apply if we're in the lob so i don't
have anything more to say
are there any questions
madam chair you did mention at the
beginning um
that you were hopeful that we could
connect to
a more normal type of meeting and
if that happens uh i just
want to be sure are you going to uh
mandate that everyone wears a mask if
we're meeting in the
lob that's not something for me to do
that's something for the
speaker and the house and the
and committee services i believe that
will be the case
thank you we will definitely be spread
from what i understand we will be spread
out in a double room
with only the committee and the staff
and possibly
one person from one of the agencies with
us
so we'll have plenty of room they've got
extra filtrate air filtration
systems that they're working on
installing in the lob
because the current air system is
not adequate and masks will be mandated
as far as i know
yes i believe that's a policy that's
been adopted by the facilities committee
and is in place now that throughout the
complex
masks are required
thank you okay
what else all right and i sent everyone
a
welcoming notice with the subcommittee
assignments because
we do most of our detailed work in
subcommittee
and i like to have standing subcommittee
so that you get to know
the areas i mean the knowing a lot about
administrative rules doesn't necessarily
mean you know anything about licensing
and so you get to work on a
group of bills that are on the same
topic
so um
can i just ask a quick question
and just let you know that my name is
pam smarling you can see it on the
screen
of course and you've all gotten emails
from me i'm the researcher for the
committee and
and um helping as a resource of of
for all kinds of things you know beyond
resource especially in this
um beyond research um
especially in the zoom age and one
question that i i want to just
ask is does everybody know how to raise
their hand electronically
does anybody have a question about that
that really is i know i just chimed in
without raising my hand and i apologize
but um
in general that helps
the meeting all right looks like
everybody's racing
and someone has a bit of feedback
yes i think it was representative scitec
i have i have muted you representative
scitec
if you could tell john that on his
computer there should be
a mute button on his computer that if he
mutes the computer then he can just use
the phone and he won't get that feedback
he should be able to hear you he's
looking for it
okay turn off your speakers
okay he's
the other item i would just briefly
mention while we're
in a sort of interim period here is that
all of the meetings are recorded and and
live streamed on youtube so if you
should
miss a meeting um that's one of the
benefits of
the remote meetings you can go on to the
house
new hampshire house of representatives
committee streaming
youtube site and see anything that you
may have missed
the other thing is that all of our
committee meetings
are open to the public and
have to comply with the right to know
laws so that
you cannot get conduct well
you cannot talk about committee business
if you have a quorum
of the committee present on a email
chain
or a phone call or zoom or whatever
unless you all happen to be of one party
in which case it's a caucus
which is allowed without being open to
the public
okay and i i will add that uh
the chat feature has intentionally been
you know taken off of this meeting
um so if you're looking for it you won't
find it
ah and then that is
deliberate to comply with right to know
exactly that that would would have had
to
be you know printed out and included in
the committee file any chat and it just
seemed simpler
to allow people to communicate if they
wanted to by text
or email or some other way during the
meeting but not through
representative schultz you've got your
hand up
yeah i just wanted to thank you for
offering the remote option because
i was hospitalized with the regular flu
lifts
at this time last year and missed
orientation and
i just wanted to thank you for making
that an option for us
um as we continue to maneuver around
covey
i appreciate that very much all right
representative pearson
yeah have we identified the uh the other
phone number that's on this panel the
one that ends in o36
yes all right let's ask
that person to unmute and say who they
are
star 6 is unmute for phones
pam can you unmute them i can only
ask to unmute and i have asked the
person to unmute but in order to do that
they need to hit star
six
that's as much as i can do
well the meantime representative fellows
um yes i i can't seem to find the email
with the committee
subcommittee assignments can you tell me
what mine is
sure
which one i'm on okay yes
the let me get the right page
all right
okay we have the committee on licensing
which representative pearson is the
chair
and that has representative allegro
schmidt and schuett as well and
santo nestaso all right
the committee on executive orders and
government organization representative
roy is the chair and has representative
broda
lonzara likus and schultz
representative yakubovic is the head of
the pension subcommittee
and that has representatives bailey
fellows
goalie and representative roy as a
second assignment
and then representative scitec is the
chair of the subcommittee on rules
which has myself representative o'brien
representative fontenot and
representative judy
thank you okay and
pam do you think you could post that um
somewhere on our committee web page
because we'll be using those
subcommittees even on things that don't
seem to fit into their uh
or normal definition
if it needs subcommittee work i can
inform about that i mean i've never
posted anything on the committee webpage
before that's
not not a practice but under new
under our current um yeah usually i post
it on the
file cabinet in the committee room but
that's not going to open
it's on the bulletin board but now we
haven't sort of and we need a virtual we
need a bulletin board right
representative lucas
just wanted to say ma the name is lekkis
uh
led and that's what happens when you
import names from another country that
uses a different alphabet and sometimes
it doesn't work quite well i understand
but it's
lackis with the e like that thank you i
apologize for the for
mispronouncing it for the last 15 years
yeah no needs i
you know i thought starting out i'd see
what i could do but i don't get offended
all right well thank you for that and i
will do my best representative font now
i just want to mention that i too did
not seem to get an email with the
subcommittee assignments so
just want to make sure they have my
correct email
on file or what have you yes well i did
that from what
i collected the emails from the web
the state website so it's what you had
last year
or last session and if you're not
make sure please do make sure that pam
has your
current and correct email so that
[Music]
that's something that the clerk has
asked that we all have one email we use
for legislative business
and make sure everybody knows about it
i'll get
an updated list from from pam
thank you okay
all right it being 9 45 don't see any
other hands up
so we should invite uh mr carlin from
the retirement system to give us
an introduction to the retirement system
madam chair the john scitec is trying to
get ahold of you here
represent scitec yes
[Music]
are you asking to have the committee
assignments
re-emailed to the entire committee
you're breaking up again
or were you asking something else
please
yes he is yes yes determine what he's
asking for that
yes yes please please
listen yes sir we will do so
all right so i will ask
mr clark i've brought mr carlin over
um and if there are others from the
retirement system
to be promoted to panelists um if you
would just raise your hands it's
probably the easiest way or marty can
tell us who
hi pam this is marty carlin if you can
please let into the meeting as panelists
george lagos
larry johansen tim crutchfield
and gerard murphy
they are all on the way if not here
just as an fyi it took about 30 seconds
for for me to rejoin
i know i was afraid you had um i had
removed you inadvertently
i was really worried
here they come that it does seem to be
taking longer than usual
and where is george
i'm on oh good
great
it looks like all of my colleagues are
here so i'll i'll
start out my name is marty carlin and
i'm the director of communications and
legislative affairs at nhrs
familiar face to to many of the veteran
members of this committee
uh been uh with a been here since the
2011 legislative session so
um coming up on ten years um now
um we're going to share the presentation
um you know among different staff
because we have the opportunity to do
that
on uh zoom so the subject matter experts
for different areas will be able to
address some of the slides we have um
typically this is an in-person
presentation and we bring handouts over
for the committee obviously
that that's not possible uh this year
but i did send pam an email
that she can forward to the full
committee with links to a number of nhrs
related documents available online
our annual reports uh some frequently
asked questions about
um topics in the news uh a link to the
uh
to our rsa 100 a and other issue
information so um and also i sent pam
a copy of the slide presentation that
we'll be giving today
uh to circulate to the committee as well
if anyone has any questions
uh you know throughout the the session
please uh reach out to me i'd be glad
to help you out whether it's a
legislative question or a question that
you received from a constituent
um i'm not sure how questions will be
handled
um this this time if people be raising
their hands and pam will
let the man or what the committee
prefers we can stop after different
sections and take questions
then why don't you do that
pause for a bit and ask questions when
before you move on to a different topic
so i'm sure there will be a number
very good thank you um and i'm going to
turn it over now to george lagos he's
the executive director of the retirement
system and he'll
just have some introductory remarks and
introduce the rest of the nhrs staff on
the
on the call thank you marty
um i'm george lagos as marty indicated
pleasure to see you all
um as marty indicated we're going to go
about this a little differently this
year in the past i've done
uh most if not all the presentations so
joining us today is of course marty
who's our director of communication
and legislative affairs uh tim
crutchfield who's our
deputy director and chief legal counsel
dry murphy who is the director of
finance and larry johansen who's the
director of investments
so they'll all be having different
segments and as you can see here's the
ground we're going to cover
and if i may madam chair we're starting
a little later than perhaps anticipated
i'd just like to know if you could tell
us
how much time if you have a limitation
in mind we have about 33 slides here so
i just want everybody to be mindful of
your time
we've blocked blocked out the morning
for it and
we will be breaking for lunch when we're
done so i i believe the
total period will depend on the
questions as much as anything
okay well i'll uh please feel free to
let us know if you'd like us to move
things along
um it's one of those things where we
don't want to rush uh past items but
um obviously some of these things are
quite complex and we can spend a lot
more time so we'll
keep that schedule in mind um so here's
here the ground uh
here's the ground we're going to cover
today um
marty is going to be discussing
membership uh tim crutchfield will cover
benefits
larry will do investments gerard and i
will split up the
contribution funding section marty's
back on for legislation
and then we have a um a very brief
summary slide
so um with that
marty it's over to you i believe
thank you george is everyone seeing the
slides that i'm sharing or
is anyone not seeing them i guess is
probably a better question
so um some of this again for veteran
committee members is going to be basic
but i know we have some newcomers so
um nhrs is a contributory multi-employer
defined benefit plan that was
established in 1967
when separate retirement plans for
teachers police fire and
state employees were merged uh
contributory means that both the member
and the employer
contribute into the plan a
multi-employer plan
is represents the fact that the costs
are shared collectively among all the
participating employers
um some states have what are called
agent plans where each municipality has
its own
essentially separate retirement plan and
separate cost structure
new hampshire is a multi-employer plan
so it's statewide
we provide retirement disability and
death benefits
as well as a post-retirement medical
subsidy
to eligible members and beneficiaries
once someone attains eligibility through
vesting they can receive a guaranteed
lifetime pension
the vesting period is 10 years in new
hampshire
or if you are working at or beyond your
normal retirement age
which is 60. our pension benefits are
funded through employee and employer
contributions
and investment income on those
investment returns have historically
provided the majority of funding for
pension benefits over the the course of
the
systems history um
nhrs isn't a state agency per se
like a department of safety or
department of ed uh what's referred to
as a component unit of state government
um so we're not directly under the
executive branch
we're overseen by a board of trustees uh
13 members they
which include active participating
members of the retirement system
representatives of uh state local
uh county and school employers uh four
members of the public and the state
treasurer
are aboard our fiduciaries which means
they are charged
with acting in the best interest of the
benefits and participants of the plan
we also have an invest independent
investment committee which we'll get
into more detail on later and they are
also fiduciaries
the legislature is the plan sponsor and
our law or planned document is rsa 100 a
staff is here to implement the statute
as well as administrative rules
uh board and board policies in besides
the
state and um internal controls on the
retirement system we also have to be
cognizant of the internal revenue code
to main the taxi
we maintain the tax exam status of the
fund
so different layers of regulation
sort of a lot govern of what we can and
can't do
in addition to rsa 100a there is a
article in the new hampshire
constitution
in part one it's article 36a and among
other things it protects the funds
in the trust for the exclusive purpose
of providing benefits
it requires the board to certify
employer contribution rates based on
sound actuarial practice and it requires
employees to pay the rates as certified
36a was adopted back in 1984.
our trustees as i said have a fiduciary
obligation
uh to ensure that the plan is adequately
funded this is sort of a
actuarial pension plan 101 graphic
representation of the equation
contributions and investment income
coming into the trust fund
need to equal benefit payments and
expenses going out and this is a
long-term equation this isn't a
year-over-year
uh balance um and these are
not to scale expenses or a fraction of
the benefit payments that go out
but it's again it's a simplified graphic
our trust fund at the close of fiscal 20
uh june 30th was at 9.134 billion
and the next slide will just sort of
show the
change in trust fund assets over the
past uh 11 years
um you know we've seen some
some dips but steady progress and over
this time while the the
trust fund has grown from a little bit
under 5 billion a little bit over nine
we've also paid out about six billion
dollars in pension benefits
um some recent initiatives that want the
kidney media to be aware of is
we've always had a focus on cyber
security and data protection but it's
it's become more enhanced as
as the threat levels um
grow over time we've seen what's
happened with with the federal
government with
the hacking issues so um you know we are
really working to
train all of our staff to be vigilant
for suspicious emails and other
uh backdoor ways into the system and
enhancing
uh protection of data and identity
authentication for
folks contacting us for benefit
information um
we've also over the last few years have
been working to
enhance our education and outreach for
members employers and
members of the public we've got uh
various social media channels and a
youtube
channel with nhrs presentations and we
try to get out
and tell our story to anyone who wants
to listen
um internally we're in the middle of a
pension application system upgrade the
product is called pension gold or pg
and we're upgrading from version two to
version three
uh this is essentially the brain of the
the retirement systems in terms of
benefit application so this is a
significant upgrade that's
um moving in in phases over a period of
years we started in january of 19 and
we're
um about a third of the way through the
project the system that we're upgrading
from was put in in 2003
2004 and a lot of the uh server and
other pieces of it are sort of reaching
end of life so
um it was it's moving within a product
within the same vendor but still
quite a quite a challenge um another new
initiative is we just
launched a contact center last month uh
to sort of streamline
calls from members and retirees in order
to get them the information without
sort of a phone tag or being being
locked in voicemail
so uh that's that's proceeding well so
far
and um finally we're searching for a new
executive director i know george will
talk about this um later but
george is retiring from the retirement
system at the end of next month
um you announced that back in the fall
and that search is ongoing
and this is my last slide uh for this
section
um this is just sort of an overview of
some significant developments since 2007
and it's you know why 2007 it's it's 14
years ago but this is really
um the beginning of the the rebuild if
you will for the new hampshire
retirement system and the recognition
among policy members and others that
changes had to be made
to strengthen the system and keep it
viable going forward
one of the biggest changes was a change
in the actuarial methodology
that was adopted in statute in 2007 uh
we'll get
kind of into the history of the unfunded
liability of the pension system later
but there was a actuarial methodology
adopted in the early 90s
that really undervalued valued the
overvalued the plan
and we weren't collecting uh the
employer contributions we should for an
extended period so that was fixed in
uh we created the legislature created an
independent investment committee that
which is performed better than peers
over the last
11 years since it was formed the
legislature put in a 30-year
amortization of our unfunded liability
the board in a few instances over the
years has reduced our assume rate of
investment return which is a key driver
of uh future costs and liabilities but
um you know they were ratcheting it
downwards to sort of reflect reality in
the markets
um and that's happened a few times
2011 again that was my first year here
uh house bill 2 was a significant change
to the retirement system it was
originally a standalone bill
uh but was folded into house bill 2 in
2011 uh did everything from increasing
member contributions which are set in
statute
uh reduced benefit accruals and benefit
formulas for
uh non-vested members and future hires
uh
changes the composition of our board
eliminated the state employer
contribution subsidy to
local employers and made many other
changes
um some of those benefit and
contribution changes were challenged in
court uh both by labor groups and
um you know by employers in regard to
the to the state subsidy and in all
those cases the
new hampshire supreme court in the
series of decisions upheld
the legislative changes and introduced
into new hampshire law the
unmistakability doctrine uh which uh
states that if there wasn't a
unmistakable intent of the legislature
in an acting
legislation future legislatures are
allowed to change it prospectively
uh and in 2017 uh there was what was
called the decennial commission this was
put into law back in 2007 as part of the
pension changes and it's a 10-year
look back at the retirement system on a
panel consisting of
representatives from the house and
senate uh employers
members retirees and members of the
public i believe uh
chair mcguire was on the decennial
commission uh you know and it was sort
of a 360
review went on for months and this is a
lengthy report available on the
general court website under the
committee documents for this
um you know it was a very thorough
review of the retirement system and a
number of recommendations were made
um several of which were enacted into
law as is or as modified
you know through the legislative process
um
generally speaking the commission found
that
nhrs was on the right track our costs
were
reasonable compared to other other
plans around the country and our
assumptions were among the more
conservative at the time
um well the commission also hired the
center for retirement research in boston
college to do an independent review and
make recommendations for the retirement
system and that sort of echoed
the same findings um and then finally
this past summer the board reduced our
assumed rate of return to 6.75 and
we'll address that in greater detail in
the funding and contribution section
that george and girardis are covering so
at that this point i'm done for a little
while and i'm gonna be turning it over
to tim crutchfield
uh to talk about membership and benefits
so i'd be glad to take any questions
on anything that's come up so far
can you hear me yes
would you repeat the mistake ability
doctrine business
yeah the uh unmistakably doctrine it
it's
it was it's a leak it can't other states
have adopted it as well but the
new hampshire supreme court introduced
it into new hampshire jurisprudence it
basically says that
unless there was an unmistakable intent
in the legislation that that legislature
did not want that change going forward
future legislatures
had the right to to modify uh plan
provisions
okay good enough
marty how much uh by lowering the
uh assumed rate of return from seven and
a quarter to six and three quarters what
did can you tell me what the effect was
on the
unfunded accrued liability with that
change yeah
um that change in others um that were
adopted
in conjunction with it such as payroll
growth and demographic changes
added about 900 million to the unfunded
liability
um the lowering of the assume rate of
return was by far the largest
component of uh the increase but there
were other changes that
contributor added up together to make it
900 million
10 percent
don't see any other questions so if we
okay i'll turn it over to tim
crutchfield our deputy director
thank you marty members of the committee
it's uh
nice to see you again over the last 20
years i've had the opportunity to appear
before the committee numerous times and
it's always good to see some familiar
faces and congratulations to the
new members of the committee as well i'm
going to address the next
five slides regarding membership and
benefits and enrollment numbers and so
forth and
hopefully at least for the returning
committee members some of these
terms and and numbers and facts and
figures will look familiar and
i'm certainly happy to take questions
along the way
starting out uh by statute nhrs
has broken the four member
classifications into two groups
group one being employees and teachers
and group two being police and fire
the teacher group the fire group and the
police group
are all mandatory participants again by
statute
the employee groups can join
nhrs if their participating employer
elects it and
certainly most of them have so if you
have
you know a town or a city uh you know
all their four
member classifications within those two
groups uh belong to nhrs
as active members and
as i said if you work full-time that
membership
is mandatory you know there there are
exceptions
to the rules and to the laws as most of
you know so i'm just going to address
the
the general terms of membership and
benefits
so under the the bullet regarding the
participating employers as you can see
there are 461
participating employers everything from
the state being the largest with about
11 000
participants to small tiny water
districts and
governmental entities that only have two
or three
members so it run it runs the gamut
[Music]
moving on to slide 10 this shows some of
the membership numbers between those
four member classes
as you can see the employee class makes
up a little more than 50 percent
of our current total membership of about
000 000 active members
in the teacher group it's interesting as
you probably know
that's a group that is declining in
terms of its demographics and its
membership
numbers uh with the the enrollments of
students declining across the state
police and fire make up relatively small
percentages of
the membership with police just a
little less than five percent and fire
only about two percent
and you can see the retirees those
numbers there as well
i will say that over the last seven
years or so that
active membership of about 48 000 has
remained relatively stable
uh while the retiree group naturally we
get more retirees every year and with
folks living longer the number of
retirees and beneficiaries is
has increased i will reference
a few slides during my presentation that
are in the appendix that you may want to
refer to
in terms of the information on this
slide i'll note that appendix slide
38 provides a 10-year trend of
of the numbers of both members and
beneficiaries
interestingly marty spoke about how in
nhrs was created by the legislature by
merging four different
retirement system plans and that first
year
there were 12 000 participants
and 36 yes only 36 beneficiaries in 1967
so the numbers have increased
significantly
uh and one thing that's uh i noted in
listening to the bios of the committee
members during the introductions is i
think it
it proves that there aren't six degrees
of separation
uh here in new hampshire between folks
that you know
have an impact have a vested interest in
nhrs and
in the lives it touches so it's we joke
around the office that
instead of six degrees of separation
they're probably only about two
you can also see that the average age of
our active participants and the average
age of our our beneficiaries and
one thing i did want to point out is
that average benefit
of less than twenty one thousand dollars
and sometimes the
the headlines are the six figure uh
annuities or benefits but
you know the average of all those almost
forty thousand people the average of
less than twenty one thousand dollars i
think would be modest
by almost any standard uh moving on to
slide 11. you can see the numbers there
of the
financial impact and outlay of the
retirement system uh
i just want to join the the first slide
in the third slide so the
816 almost 17 million dollars and
benefits paid out 80 percent of that
stays in new hampshire so i know my
colleagues are always leery of me doing
lawyer math but
that's over 650 million dollars that
stays in the state of new hampshire
and has a significant impact on the new
hampshire economy
the middle bullet talks about a medical
subsidy benefit
that's a benefit available to
essentially a closed pool
of retirees that pays a a stipend if you
will toward
health insurance that's offered through
retirees former employers
there are about 10 000 retirees and
beneficiaries that
are covered under the medical subsidy
now and as i said it's a closed group
state employees had to have retired by
july of 2004 teachers and political sub
retirees had to retire by july of 2009
and their for group twos police and fire
they had to be
active or retired uh by june of 2000 so
again that that number of about 10 000
folks now will only
get smaller as time goes on
moving on now to slide 12.
the four types of retirement service is
by far
you know the largest number of annuities
that we pay out but
we also offer a disability benefit and
that's broken into two different
types one is work related if you get
hurt on the job as we refer to it as
accidental disability retirement and
then there's ordinary disability
retirement
you know you get sick or injured outside
the workforce
there's early retirement which is a
combination of years of service and age
i don't want to get too far down in the
in the weeds but
if you have say you're you're 50 years
old and you have 30 years of service
as a teacher you could qualify for
what's referred to as an early service
retirement
which would normally be age 60 for the
normal retirement age
for those folks that do elect for early
service retirement
there is a reduction by taking early
service as opposed to
waiting until age 60.
vested deferred retirement refers to
a point of time in which a member
qualifies for a benefit
but they leave their participating
employer before they actually
retire so perhaps they have 20 years of
service but they
they leave and take another position
with a non-participating employer
so they have preserved the right to that
benefit and
when they get to age 60 or later in most
cases and they want to utilize it then
they can then apply for that vested
deferred retirement benefit
the next bullet refers to the different
benefit provisions for the two groups
again group one employees and teachers
group two uh police and fire
and and a large part of the the
different benefit provisions
uh have to do with the fact that group
two
members do not have access to social
security in new hampshire so you'll see
some slides later on that shows
the average group two benefit is higher
than those for group one but
in large part it's to make up for the
lack of social security as well as they
typically have a
shorter work history due to the
dangerous level of public safety
the next bullet speaks to the different
benefit provisions based on
vested by or hired by date again vested
vested in our terminology means at that
point in which you're entitled to a
benefit
now marty mentioned hb2 back in 2011
that established essentially two tiers
of benefits for both groups and nhrs
and it depends on if members were vested
by uh 1 112 or hired prior to 7-1-11 and
that created the two tiers
there are different formulas for the
benefits between group 1 and group 2.
again i'll refer to the appendix under
slide
40. it talks about or gives an example
of a typical group one benefit
slide 41 gives an example of a typical
group two benefit uh by the the
different components of what makes up
uh a benefit the
the months of creditable service the
average final compensation and the
benefit multiplier the
creditable service is counted in terms
of months for nhrs participants
and again going back to that hired by or
bested by date
uh the the average final compensation
is either based on an average of your
high three years
or or your high five years and again
those slides 40 and 41 will give you an
example of that
moving now to slide 13.
again i spoke earlier of the relatively
modest benefits
that nhrs pays its its
retirees and beneficiaries i i think the
numbers are right there for you
again the the police and fire jump out
in terms of the group one
uh as being higher but again they they
typically have a shorter
uh work history and the the not
entitled to social security
the note on the automatic cost of living
adjustments is interesting because those
cost of living or
cola adjustments are granted by the
legislature last year a cola was granted
for the first time since 2010
that was 1.5 up to the first 50
000 of a benefit so it was a maximum of
750 dollars
folks had to be retired uh since 7-1-14
so that impacted about 30 000 out of the
almost 40 000 retirees were then
eligible for the cola
it was phased in beginning this past
august
based on participants retirement month
and so august through next july is how
the this coming july is how the
coals will be paid and the kohler was
funded through employer contributions
uh over the next 20 years at a cost of
about 20
67 million dollars through the general
fund
moving on to slide 14 my last slide
again i spoke briefly about perhaps
the six figure the rare six figure
benefits get the headlines but as you
can see the vast majority
of our retirees and beneficiaries
aren't getting rich on their nhrs
retirements uh
you know with 28 percent or about 11 000
of our 48 or 39 000
make less than 10 thousand dollars a
year in their retirement annuity
uh you know two-thirds are under
twenty-five thousand dollars
uh and ninety-four percent make less
than the fifty thousand so again
um they work uh they earn it uh they're
not getting rich by their retirement
benefit
an average benefit of less than twenty
one thousand dollars
that concludes my portion of the
presentation i'm happy to take any
questions before turning it over to
larry johansen to discuss
investments
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair i thank you tim
for your presentation
good to see you again um i'm wondering
i recall during the time
roughly at the very beginning of the
restructuring of the retirement system
that was undertaken as a result of
house bill what was it 683 or something
like that
um that got into a whole series of the
the decisions that have been taken back
in the 90s that
had resulted in kind of a devastating
diminution of the
the trust fund corpus
and and and some unsustainable long-term
programs uh given the financial status
of the
retirement system uh so the colas
and the uh the the healthcare subsidies
which were basically kind of
discontinued
uh except for uh the the
health care benefit which was continued
for those people that were contractually
entitled to it uh but there were a lot
of people that came and testified
with regard to their status and so forth
and
uh and i remember seeing a lot of those
people
um many of them had been retired for
many years and were
the the red hat ladies you probably saw
them yourself
uh who came in um and
a lot of those people were in their high
80s and 90s and some even older
who had been retired for decades uh
but um but they also had been
uh working at a time when their earnings
were very very low
so the figure that you on the screen
that you're showing us
the annual benefit under ten thousand
dollars
28 of the people so
is that basically those are the people
who are who've been in the retirement
system
for in many cases decades now
most of many of them would have passed
away in the meantime
but others you know have aged into that
status
um so they uh these are people who
actually had very very low earnings
was that not the case and that so that
the figure
of under 10 000 um
is it has to be understood in
in terms of who those people are is that
not correct
uh thank you representative schmidt i i
would offer
a little different perspective that
certainly
there probably are a few older much
older folks who
worked a traditional working career but
because of the earnings at that time
resulted in a very low pension but more
likely i suggest that the
uh the 10 000 a year or less are folks
who
didn't have a long career didn't have a
30-year teacher career or
20-year public safety career that
perhaps they only worked
five or six years but they kept kept
their money in and then they
you know then when they aged into it age
60 or 65 as the case may be they started
collecting
it so i would suggest it's probably more
representative
of a fewer years of service than
a traditional long working career at a
low wage
i think that's very helpful to make that
uh
distinction um because
the the brand new members of the
committee who are seeing all this
information for the first time
uh will have a hard time understanding
that
now how are you going to help
all of us try to recover uh from
you know six months of enforced uh
absence
and inactivity in the legislature to to
deal with these situations
and the people who are brand new unless
they're in the retirement system
themselves
i don't have any knowledge of this is
there going to be some
like manuals and so forth so people
can study this in in more detail
that could be provided to the committee
members we certainly can and i'll defer
to
both marty and george but we'll make
this information and certainly this
uh presentation on the slides available
uh if we haven't already immediately
following the conclusion of today's
meeting at any time there's a question
from
any of you are happy to answer it and
provide the information
in whatever form you deem best
representative schmidt this is marty
carlin if i i can jump in i think
i might have mentioned this while tim
was transitioning into the
participant phase but i i did send pam a
series of links to all of our annual
financial reports
uh and some other handouts and
supplemental material that
uh would be useful background for the
committee to to look at and we can we
can definitely if there's
additional information that's available
we can provide that on request but
um i would point out the annual
financial report
uh is has a lot of data in it it's um
unlike a sort of a news article with an
inverted pyramid all the
the better information in the annual
report is towards the back it's all sort
of the statistical and data information
it's
formatted in such a way that the i cut
to meet the accounting standards
the summary uh financial report is only
about 10 pages and that's a really
quick reference to a lot of high-level
information on the retirement system and
i'd recommend
uh checking that out as well
thank you very much that's helpful
representative
i'm sorry i lost audio were you calling
on me
yes ma'am yeah very handy thank you
i just wanted to point out to the new
members of the committee all
that uh if you go on to the
new hampshire retirement system website
there's a lot of information available
there also
and that will do what employees and
employees
have access regarding the retirement
system also
thank you thank you representative
stuart i i don't want to sound like a
telemarketer but
www.nhrs.org
thank you very much further hand so
please continue
uh yes wait i have a question can you
hear me
yes sir representative please ask
uh first of you're talking about people
getting an average benefit of under 10k
you
said i thought i heard you say people
have left their money in
for only four or five years and left i
thought you needed to take 10 years to
get vested
or that is if you're 10 years you just
get your money back
if you stayed less than 10 you could get
your money back
if you stay 10 that's typically the the
magic figure from
many folks who are participating now
that they would then become
vested i.e entitled to a benefit the
other way
to be vested and be entitled to a
benefit
is to age in meaning if you started
a a career or a second career for a
participating employer
at age 55 for example and you worked
until age 60 by hitting age
60 even though you only had five years
of service
you would also be entitled to a benefit
so this would not work for somebody who
was 20 years old
and left their five years
correct they would not be entitled to a
benefit thank you
you're welcome
okay thank you good morning and it's uh
good to be here with
the committee um i'm going to cover the
next five slides
um the investment program at the new
hampshire retirement system
at a very high level the
responsibilities is
is broadly distributed between the board
of trustees a
13-member board representing employers
members taxpayers they actually approve
the investment policy including the
asset allocation
and hire the investment consultant both
of which based upon recommendations of
the
independent investment committee the
independent investment committee created
by statute
out of the first commission in o7
became effective january 1 of 2009
as i mentioned they recommend the
investment policy to the board
essentially they implement that
investment policy they oversee
all of the investments of the retirement
system
they hire the service providers the
asset managers
they hire the consultants and or the
custodian rather and they prepare as as
was alluded to earlier
a comprehensive annual investment report
that was just
finished and is is posted on our website
um in appendix on slide 36
is a list of the current members of the
investment committee it's a six-member
committee
two from the board appointed by the
board chair three independent members
and then a member who is a member of the
retirement system
on the next slide
this is our asset allocation we look at
this continuously
[Music]
we have a very long-term horizon um
25 plus years you think about a
new member of the retirement system 20
years plus or minus
retires at 65
and then and then lives another 20-plus
years in retirement that's a very
long-term horizon
we continuously manage risk and
liquidity
one of the things that that we did when
the
um pandemic first started is managed
our cash needs over a 90-day basis as
opposed to a 30-day basis
we have a modest negative cash flow in
the retirement system
meaning that when you add up all of the
member and employer contributions
that's slightly less than or yeah
slightly less than the
benefit payments that are paid so we
need to manage that very carefully
when when the pandemic first started and
the economic impact and you will all
recall the
significant downturn in march of last
year we wanted to make sure that we had
sufficient cash
to meet benefit payments every month um
it's a well-diversified portfolio you
can see
that all of the asset classes are
close to targets and well within the
range as part of the asset allocation
that the board adopts recommended by the
investment committee
there's a target allocation but then a
range around that so you're not
doing a round trip to try to get back to
it
within a very narrow range on the next
slide
these are our returns at june 30.
obviously the one-year return was
dramatically
impacted by the economic impact of the
pandemic primarily in the first quarter
of
2020 but there was some recovery in the
second quarter but not
complete longer term returns are listed
here
i would point out that at the board
meeting yesterday we reviewed
performance through november 30th
um the performance has dramatically
rebounded since
the end of the fiscal year 14.2
for the five months ending uh november
30th
and then on a longer term basis for
three years 7.1
five years 8.7 and 10 years 8.6 so
the economic impact for the first two
quarters of
2020 have turned around significantly
again the assumed rate of return is 6.75
over the long term
we want to exceed that next slide please
this is the annual returns over long
periods of time
one of the things that this slide is is
very helpful in pointing out is
why we do asset smoothing over five
years
the rate setting valuations are in the
odd year
if we didn't smooth the valuation as of
would have resulted in a dramatic
increase
in employer contribution rates and then
two years later and 11
with that very spike and positive
performance
obviously those employer rates would
have dropped dramatically so so the
smoothing
helps um keep contribution rates
relatively stable over time next slide
please
one of the things marty alluded to
earlier is the development of the
independent investment committee
dramatically improved performance for
the retirement system since its
inception
over the past 10 years our investment
performance has been better than 9
74 of our peers meaning we're almost
in the top quartile since the inception
the investment committee has um created
to approximately 270 million dollars
more than
um had we earned the average return of
of the peers um one other slide i would
point to you in the
appendix is slide 42 in addition to
managing
the assets we are very cognizant of
managing our expenses
slide 42 demonstrates that our
expenses on investments are dramatically
less than peers
it also demonstrates that our
administrative expenses the
cost of running the retirement system
are dramatically less than
peers before i turn this over to
gerard for the next slide of slides are
there any questions from the
members of the committee
yes i had my hand raised this is uh
representative shewett
um i'm curious you mentioned
the specific return for the first
quarter
of 2020 what was the return for the
second quarter
and was that just for the or was that
for the first
six months and what was the actual
percentage
i i don't have that representative off
the top of my head
the the return for the first quarter of
2020 was a negative return
it was slightly positive for the second
quarter of 2020.
um the the total return for the fiscal
year was 1.1
but as a follow-up we can certainly send
the committee that information
thank you thank you mr johansen please
do send us that information
because the way the markets have been
whipsawed we we are we're interested to
see what's
what's going on representative pearson
thank you uh madam chair before before
before i get into this um can you repeat
that number that you said
was it 14.2
i wrote down end of november 30th is
that
that's for the five months ending
november 30th
okay so my my question is this because
my
my concern is with the investment
committee we
my understanding is it used to meet
quarterly that changed
to a more frequent time period
the the act the actions
in the market um and and to give you a
bit of my background
on that so where i'm coming from is my
frame of reference i had a
talking baby on a television convinced
me to download an app
eight years ago and start investing in
my spare time
i buy no means am someone that is
qualified to
give anybody any investing advice okay
but me goofing around has pulled
easily double digit numbers um
you know over this time period in in
doing a little you know personal
investing in
you know just just like i said very
rudimentary amateur
you know looking at the way the market
moved the market didn't fall off a cliff
the market slid
from december of 19 through april and
may
now with the new hampshire retirement
system having an investment committee
and having paid professionals
looking at the allocation of assets
within the retirement system
what moves did the retirement
system make while that slide was
occurring
because if we just sat there and watched
it happen
i got a 10 year old nephew that can do
that
you know we're paying professionals to
to make moves
in reaction to what is currently
happening and
i think the question that really needs
to be answered is what moves were made
so you can help restore some confidence
in this
in this committee um that the investment
committee
is actually doing anything
well first the the investment committee
as i mentioned was created in
january one of 09 they have met
monthly since they're correct since
their creation so so the committee meets
ev every month um second
um the committee sets
based upon um they recommend the asset
allocation to
to the board and and the committee and
the board
are long-term investors um the the
problem
that happens with an attempt at market
timing
is you have to get both decisions
exactly right
whether you're selling and buying or
buying and then
selling so the committee while
was cognizant of what was going on did
not make any short-term changes in the
asset allocation
so follow mountain chair follow up
yeah so a fancy way of telling me you
guys
watched you were more they were more
spectators than partic
active participants and what happened in
the first quarter of 2020
no i i wouldn't say they were part they
were um
spectators they they were cognizant of
what was happening
they recognized that this was
potentially a very short-term
change um and have been rewarded
for staying the course
thank you madam chair thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair uh
one question and it's good to hear that
we're in the top
74 of uh peers in investing
but if i look at
the past report i believe
this one percent was a lot worse than
our peers did
and what was our percentage if could you
refresh my mind as to what that memory
of what that percentage was where we
stood
with this one percent because i think
that's part of the reason
why we failed 1.1 for the fiscal year
ending june 30
um put us in the in the bottom decile of
piers
and that was primarily because
for that one year period um the s p
500 outperformed everything
um the barclays ag outperformed
everything on the fixed income side the
portfolio was well diversified
um and did not own just the s p 500
nor did it just own the um barclays ag
and as i mentioned the performance
through november
um 30th um has has rewarded that
well-diversified portfolio
so the the one-year return and the
bottom decile
is is an anomaly um primarily based upon
the the very strong performance of the s
p 500 and
the barclays ag
was the follow-up thank you madam chair
what were the returns of those that were
in the uh upper percentage of
this past year if we were to look at
what comparing our 1.1 percent to what
they were making
where were they were in the the
low single digits there was a very
narrow range between
the top and the bottom thank you
representative of it um thank you
can you give me the latest number on the
unfunded liabilities side
please yeah our funded ratio is
is approximately 61 percent our unfunded
liabilities approximately six billion
dollars there are
slides later on that go into the detail
of that
thank you any other questions
i'd like to say that when i after
talking with people at the session
i checked one of my retirement accounts
and i was down three and a half percent
june to june
but up over the course of 2020 so i
it was a difficult period as you all
know
madam chair this is uh george
legislative just mentioned
um i appreciate the nature of the
questions we're hearing
um but i think the thing i would
emphasize um
is that you know this is the this is
in largely in part what happens when you
look at snapshots and not the movie
um you know the the track record over
the past 10 years has been excellent
uh we're in the top 26 percent not the
top 74 percent over that period
and june 30 of uh 20
um is one day and because of the way
this process works
every that that day june 30 of every
year is when the picture is taken
so it's uh one's one frame in a movie
and what counts is the movie so over
over that time period uh the results
have been
excellent and again if you look at where
we are
in the first five months of the current
fiscal year we're double digits 14
and if you just look at that in
comparison in addition to where we just
entered the last fiscal year
you can see how things over time give
you a much different impression than
they do if you pick any particular day
so not to belabor it but i think that's
an important point to be made
isn't it like us uh thank you madam
chair
uh please remind me what is the number
of years that uh
uh you know the the data is averaged
over to determine the rates that the uh
participating employers pay i mean what
i'm wondering is
um to what extent is this you know one
year's result
gonna have uh increased costs for uh you
know the municipalities and
uh other employers as i mentioned
on one of the earlier slides that one
year
at 20 will be smoothed over
five years the next rate setting
valuation will be june 30
21 um and and um obviously i don't know
what our performance will be for the
fiscal year ending 21
but that will be in addition to the
prior four years
and smoothed over that period par part
of
the the reduction in the assumed rate of
return
that the board adopted um last spring
was due to the lower expectations across
all the capital markets um as
we move forward uh follow-up please
follow up um so was there an
increase um said at the end of june
and what the municipalities had to pay i
understand it would have been
less than the full amount because it's
averaged over five years but was there
an increase
the the employer rates that were
certified by the board
in september of 20
was based upon the actual valuation
at june 30 19. so the
the results of june 3020 and the results
of june 30
to be 21 will be incorporated in the
valuation as of 21 to set the rates
in 22. so so the rates set in
uh september of 20 were based upon the
the fiscal year ending june 30 19.
okay thank you representative golick
thank you manager just one quick
question i guess
probably for larry if i know
our fiscal year goes
july 1 to june 30 um and we're getting
our returns based on that time frame
can is there a significant difference
using
that time frame versus using a january
1 to december 30th time frame in the
market
over one period over one year period yes
the
calendar year returns versus the fiscal
year returns can be
dramatically different um
we don't have the 12 31 performance
um as of yet we expect that
sometime next week but um clearly
the the second half of 20 is
dramatically better than the first half
of 20 and i expect that to be
um substantially better than the fiscal
year returns
but but again these are one-year returns
to reiterate what what george said is
we are a long-term investor and
one-year returns are important but the
longer-term returns are
much more important follow-up madam
chair
follow-up uh yeah i'm not talking just
about this year i'm talking about
historically
year-over-year using that time frame of
january to december versus
july to june and i mean you know
they will be different but over the long
term the averages will still be
comparable thank you
other questions okay thank you
thank you
okay i think that's me uh good morning
everyone
i'm gerard murphy i'm the director of
finance here at nhrs
and i will be uh discussing uh the next
slides
the next four slides beginning on number
20 here
so here we go if you recall the trust
fund equation
from a few slides earlier there are two
inputs on the left side of that equation
now that larry has covered the
investment income i'll talk a little bit
about the the other input contributions
contribution amounts are calculated as
percentage rates of payroll for members
covered by nhrs
what we refer to as covered payroll
and there are two types as you've heard
earlier there are two types of
of contributions coming into nhrs the
first
are member contributions and they are
set in state statute
with the rates for the four different
plans listed here on this slide
these rates tend not to change very
often as it has been
over 10 years since those rent since
those rates have have last
changed the other contribution
type is employer contributions these
contribution rates are calculated every
two years
in our odd year actuarial valuation
reports
and then certified by the nhrs board of
trustees
there are different rates for each of
the four member groups
and each rate is made up of uh the three
components
the normal cost the unfunded actuarial
accrued liability
and the medical subsidy uh we'll talk a
little more about these components
in a bit but the last thing i wanted to
mention
from this slide was that last bullet
regarding
the fact that political subdivisions
have been pla
paying the full employer contribution
cost for
all of their nhrs members since the
state subsidy was repealed in
2011. for a number of years before that
the state had been paying a portion of
the employer contributions for teachers
police and fire members for all local
employers
next slide please okay
all right so the three components
of the rates normal cost
normal cost is just the basics the
estimated cost of pension benefits as
they are earned
in the absence of of any other factors
the member contributions that we talked
about on the last page cover most of the
normal cost with the employer rate
with the component of the employer rate
making up the difference
the the next component of the employer
rate is the portion that goes to pay off
the unfunded liability the ual
this is the estimated value of benefits
accrued in the past but not yet
funded it is determined by the actuaries
and calculated by comparing the
actuarial present value of projected
benefits
with the actuarial value of trust assets
and the difference
is the ual the ual gets a lot of
attention and it
makes up a substantial portion of the
contribution rates for nhrs employers
as you will see in a later slide
as of 6 30 20 the the nhrs ual balance
was 6.04 billion
and this resulted in a funded ratio of
61 percent
there are a number of factors driving
this current ual balance
first up were the artificially low
employer contributions
caused by a flawed statutory funding
methodology
put in place in response to economic
pressure back in the 90s
the this this flawed funding methodology
was coupled with an extended period of
transferring
uh so-called excess earnings returns
above a certain threshold
out of the pension trust and into the
special account
um these the these conditions were then
exasp
were then exacerbated by the financial
crisis in 08 and 09
and then the third main driver of the uh
the growth in the ual has been the
reductions
have been the reductions in the assumed
rate of return in 2011
2016 and most recently in 2020.
all of these reductions were enacted in
response to recommendations from our
actuaries
after conducting actuarial experience
studies
uh the last thing about the u the ual
that i wanted to mention was the
amortization schedule
a little over 10 years ago the
legislature enacted a closed 30-year
period to pay off the uaal
uh that period ended in 20 or will end
in 2039
uh then a few years ago layered
amortization was introduced
the closed period that original closed
period with
20 years remaining was kept in place for
the ual balance
as of 6 30 2017 and then
the change in the ual for every two year
period
after that will then be amortized over a
not to exceed 20 years so there will be
a layer every two years
to amortize changes to the ual
and this this layered amortization was
put into place to
eliminate uh some of the volatility that
would have been present
under the old set closed structure of
that
that 30 years
so let's see where am i okay uh the last
component
of the employer rate so we had we had
the uh
the normal cost the unfunded liability
and then the last component it's the
medical subsidy
and as you heard uh before uh
eligibility for this subsidy program is
now closed
it's a it's a dwindling population and
funding is determined on a pay-as-you-go
basis
so it's really enough to keep the
program running with
uh with margins put in place in case
experience comes in higher
okay if we could move to the next slide
please
okay so
here we have our two main work products
of our actuarial consultant um
we actually we get a valuation report
every year however the even year reports
are scaled down versions
and they really only provide us with the
information we need uh
to complete our annual financial
statements and be in compliance with
with gasby requirements
but the um but the
uh the odd year valuation reports can
they're they're beefed up
versions of the reports and they contain
all of the information
necessary for the board to set rates
um as we discussed before the reports
have calculations for present value of
projected benefits for the actuarial
value of assets
uh deriving the the ual and and the
funded ratio
the the second report listed on this
slide is the actuarial experience study
which is conducted every four years
these reports compare actual experience
with the actuarial
assumptions in place in order to
determine if changes to those
assumptions should be made
there are two types of actuarial
assumptions demographic and economic
the demographic assumptions include
things like mortality rates retirement
rates
system withdrawal rates disability rates
that sort of thing
where the economic assumptions include
the assumed rate of return
the wage inflation rate um and the price
inflation rate
the most recent experience study covered
the four-year period
fiscal years 2016 to 2019
and it was presented to the board in the
spring of 2020.
the assumption changes recommended in
that report were then used
in the 630-19 actuarial evaluation
report presented to the
board in the summer of 2020 and this
report was then used to certify rates
for the 2223 biennium
in september of 2020.
next slide please
so what what did the board do
based on the recommendations contained
in the the 16 to 19 experience study
and input from nhrs staff our
independent investment consultant
and a number of economic experts the
board voted to change assumptions both
demographic
and economic on the demographic side the
biggest impact was the change
to mortality rates and this was was
driven mainly by the adoption of
new public pension plan mortality tables
uh they're a relatively new creation
specific to public pension plans
on the economic side you can see those
changes listed on the slide here
wage growth and inflation rates were
decreased i want to point out
as you heard before there's a lower wage
growth
for teachers and that's due to the
long-term decline in the population of
teachers so they're
they're at a slightly lower rate than
the other three uh employee groups
and then obviously as you've you've all
heard the change with the biggest impact
was the reduction to the uh the a the
assumed rate of return
so with that that ends my my portion of
the presentation
uh before i turn it before i turn it
back over to george i'd be happy to try
and answer any questions folks have
i don't oh representative goalie
thank you madam chair uh
just one quick question i have because
it
dramatically increased the unfunded
accrued liability
was reducing the assumed rate of return
you had the option looking at the
minutes of going to 7
versus a 6.75 and knowing what that was
going to do to the
unfunded accrued liability and also
to the municipalities in the rate
setting why did
you choose why did you choose 6.75 when
the 7
option was available
let's see um george did you what
were you going to cover that topic in
your portion next yeah
yeah certainly and i'm happy to just
address it now because we'll come to it
anyway in a minute
um so um first of all our actuary
uh told us that 7.25 wouldn't be
considered as actuarially reasonable so
that was the starting point so knowing
that we knew we had to make a change
the actuary said that a range from about
6.25 to
7 would be considered in the reasonable
range but also recommended
uh made it clear that his recommendation
would have been 6.75 and that he would
have
frankly would have preferred a number
low than that lower than that but he was
willing to take
6.75 as being reasonable and that would
be his recommendation so he did
acknowledge he would accept seven
but what we thought that would do would
i shouldn't say we because uh first of
all staff doesn't vote on this this is a
board decision
but our recommendation from the staff
standpoint was 6.75 as well
so that being said i would mention also
the investment committee actually came
up with 6.5
as the number so the the there are a
number of different
ways you can look at it and our point of
view was that
uh the message we were clearly getting
from the actuary was
that if we picked a number higher than
6.75
um we would likely be revisiting it in
two-year time period
and we don't like to be jumping around
um
you know reviewing um the assumed rate
of return on
a two-year time period we prefer to do
it um every four or five years
in line with the experienced study so
you know the objective of the board is
to properly price the plan to
adopt those assumptions that we think
most closely reflect
what the actual experience has been and
what it's likely to be in the future
with the advice
from a number of sources so that's
that's how the vote came out
manager follow-up
and george i mean we all know that
it also has the impact on the rates that
municipalities pay
um and i understand you don't want to
revisit it every two years
but the hit cities and towns were taking
with that change
i mean wouldn't it have been reasonable
to revisit it in two years and set it at
seven percent
well i i think you know it was within
the board's discretion to make that
decision
but i think the reason personally i
think the decision was a good one
was that their job is to properly set
the assumptions based on
the information provided and to the
extent that
you don't make those adjustments every
time you
make an adjustment in a way that causes
you to come back and adjust it again
just continues to add to the unfunded
liability because what that
what that does is you you end up under
funding
if you're not funding in accordance with
what reality ends up being
so it creates a greater probability that
you're adding to the unfunded liability
more than you would be by adjusting it
now you're actually strengthening the
plan by bringing in more dollars
is the impact substantial yes it is but
it's also realistic in terms of what the
plan experience has been and what
all of our economic experts are telling
us we should be expecting
and and i can tell you a representative
goalie that that issue itself wasn't
lost at all on the board that was part
of the discussion
it was fully contemplated and that was
the decision of the board
taking all factors into consideration
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair my question is
referring to uh slide number 20
when you look at the group 1 employees
both groups are at their contribution
rates
and the same percentile but there seems
to be
a disparity on the group 2 employees
what is the difference between the
police and fire why are those
two numbers different and
who actually stays longer out of those
to group two
uh is the fire stay longer or the police
stay longer
in terms of employment i can address
that
um folks uh this is marty
um the prior to 2011 the group two rates
were the same they were both nine point
three percent of pay for police and fire
uh house bill two did create a a larger
rate um employer country employee member
contribution rate for fire
um i was pretty much living in the
basement that legislative session and i
i
attended all the hearings i don't recall
a stated rationale for why the
difference between police and fire
you know other than the fact that at
that time 10 years ago the
um fire plan as in as a component of the
overall plan was was
more poorly funded than the police plan
uh but but i
there wasn't a lot of discussion about
why those numbers uh are disparate
and an answer to your second question uh
firefighters are
among the longer they they tend to
average out working longer than police
um i i could get the averages for you i
just um
retirees who police and fire retirees
retiring in 2019 the average service for
a firefighter was 26 years
and the average service for a police
officer was 23
um so they they do tend to work longer
historically
i'll follow up if i may madam chair
follow up
so interpret my from what you told me my
interpretation to tell my friends
basically the firefighters are penalized
within this system
by paying more in the contribution rate
even though they're staying longer and
making
uh more heftier contributions to the
retirement system
than the other group two group
i i would say it was a legislative
decision and then
you know we wouldn't nhrs wouldn't say
you know whether it was fair or unfair
but that was
what what the majority of the
legislature chose to enact back in 2011.
representative thank you
so um i don't fully understand that's a
understatement the uh the layered uh
approach to dealing with the
um the unfunded uh liability and i'm not
looking for a you know detailed
presentation at this point
but i have a general question that is
that uh uh
on the effect of it and that is you know
assuming
you know that we don't change the rules
and assuming the given
assumptions play out when would we
expect to be at a hundred percent funded
um i'll take that uh this is george
um the the reality is so there's now
two different aspects to the
amortization of unfunded liability
the original unfunded liability that was
sort of fixed at 2017
um is we're now about 11 years into that
so at 39 that original part of the
unfunded liability
should be at zero okay uh well what's
that on this
i missed the date 2039.
thank you right so um
but at 2039 there will be a series of
layered amortization schedules that will
depend on the gains and losses
that occur between now and then and that
number
will be is an unknown right now so that
there could uh very well be an unfunded
liability in 2039 depending upon the
experience of the plan
um starting with the last value
valuation through the
2039 date but there's no way at this
point in time of telling you what that
number might be
all right um this is marty
sorry follow up
dylan martin well i'm sorry i just uh
wanted to mention as well it was sort of
a
quick cliff notes version of thinking
added is when the amortization was put
in
in legislation in 2007 beginning in 2010
um the the intent was to be 100 funded
by 2039
though the layering was put in as a
recommendation of the decennial
commission back in 2017 because
as you get closer to 2039 you'd be much
more subject to market fluctuations you
could have
tremendous swings in employer
contributions so the layering is sort of
a safety valve it doesn't we won't be
100 funded in 2039
but there's there's there's sort of a
manageable 20-year
tranches to pay off you know or
recognize future gains and losses
so we wouldn't ever theoretically get to
where we are now
you know we'd be pretty close to 100 but
those other layers would be paid off
you know going forward so so the the
intergenerational equity
for taxpayers in different periods would
would be more balanced than it is now
okay thank you the the other
issue with respect to the layered
amortization
is there was no provision in the statute
as to how to amortize any gains and
losses beyond 2039
so what would have happened is every two
years if there was a gain the rate would
go down and you'd have to amortize that
immediately
there was a loss the rate would go up
and you have to amortize that
immediately so this 20-year layered
ammonization
allows this to go on beyond 2039.
representative pearson had a question
yeah thank you madam chair um
i know we're not changing slides here
that would be a little helpful
if uh if it matches what the topic is
um but the you mentioned the
for those especially that are that are
new you mentioned the formation
of the retirement system in 1967
the the agreement that was made in 1967
looks a whole lot different
than the makeup of the system today
and i was wondering if you could just
touch on the states the state's
responsibility in 1967 when they
when they created the nhrs
versus what the state is doing as far as
their responsibility
in 2021.
um marty i trust that question goes to
the
subsidy of municipal local governmental
rates so why don't you tackle that yeah
i'm a bit of the class historian um at
nhrs so
when rsa 100a was enacted uh back in 67
i've got an original law book the the
whole statute was about 38 pages long
and
you know same margins now the the law
books about 160 pages so there have been
changes
throughout the history of nhrs in terms
of the state's obligation uh in 67
um the state was paying 40 of the cost
for
teachers um that was actually a remnant
from the previous
um legacy plan for teachers only you
know the teachers retirement system
they've been paying that at least since
the early 50s as far back as i can tell
um back in 1977 the legislature
changed the subsidy so they were paying
for teachers police and fire and that
was in effect
um until 2009 1011 when the
subsidy was ratcheted down from to 30
percent one year 25 the next year and
then
eliminated
representatives well i had a follow-up
sorry i couldn't get to my
on my channel i apologize
um so just so i i i understand what
you're
you're saying marty
the the makeup today is is substantially
different
than the when the the retirement system
was
formed
where the state has basically just
abandoned its its agreed upon
responsibility
if i'm if i'm following your math and
calendars correctly here
the
that did that have an effect on the
unfunded liability or was that entirely
downshifted to the
to the local level if you will i know
the state there's some state agencies
involved but you get what i'm saying
yeah it didn't change the liability it
just shifted the cost
um you know from the amount that the
state was paying on behalf of the
municipalities that cost moved over
um so so you think about it you know the
other way for
for a number of years for teachers
police and fire
localities and school districts are
paying 65 percent of what the total rate
was and then ended up paying 100
so that elimination of the 35 subsidy
was about a 50
increase in what their dollar amounts
they were paying to the retirement
system even though the liability
remained the same and this
change was um challenged by some
municipalities
and upheld by the supreme court i think
that decision came out in maybe 10 or
11.
representative show up thank you man
[Music]
i think this is a fairly simple question
for mr murphy
uh you mentioned that the mortality
rates
had changed did those rates increase or
decrease
thanks representative stewart um
basically
the the experience mortality experience
has improved um folks as we all have
heard
from countless sources um folks are
are living longer um
as time goes on so that it was a cost
there was a cost associated with the
with the changes to the mortality
assumptions you are correct
thank you very much
thank you madam chair
uh mr crowley could you kindly give
those dates again so into
in in 67 40
was for the teachers 40 of the cost
plan was for teachers and then in 77 it
was
reduced to 35 but it included police and
fire
and when did 25 when in 2011 did you say
um i i believe the the legislation was
passed in 09
so fiscal 10 it was 30
fiscal 11 it was a 25 subsidy
and the original law that was enacted 09
was restoring it to 35
for fiscal 12 but the legislature in
eliminated the subsidy instead i i've
got a i've got the
sort of a white paper on this on the uh
nhrs website and i'll send it over to
pam to distribute to the committee if
anyone's interested thank you i think
there will be a lot of people interested
representative o'brien thank you madam
chair
um i think if i'm correct past
legislators came up with
people who did do some shift coverage or
overtime work
uh such as details and such and
in the past that money uh when they got
their pay for that
uh in the group two particularly what
we're talking about went into their
retirement benefit but then i think
that was kind of cut back and if it was
cut back if somebody worked at overtime
shift and yet the pension system did
take
a percentage the normal percentage out
of that
uh shift did that increase the unfunded
liability
when somebody's working uh 25 to 30
years
uh that's a substantial chunk of change
that
was lost by the retirement system
yes but the benefits were changed also
it probably had an actuarial impact but
it was it
it you know it's sort of on the margins
they i think the actuary
looked at that particular aspect
significantly but but for the record
any uh police and fire members hired
after july first of 11
uh the detail pay doesn't count towards
their pension calculation anymore and
neither the member nor their employer
pay contributions to nhrs on that money
so it's
it's considered non-pensionable
compensation
i don't see any more questions right now
so let's go on
okay thank you madam chair so
we're on slide 24. um some of these
issues
were things we just talked about but
why why did the board take the action
they did well the actuarial
experience over the past four years
showed that the assumptions didn't
support
uh the rates that were in place um the
economic and investment forecasts that
the board received
showed that inflation was going to be
very limited so therefore
the interest rate had to be taken into
consideration and also investment
returns
were universally seen by i think there
were a total of 17 or 19
different investment operations that
were taken into consideration by
our actuaries and then others by the
investment committee as well
but clearly all expectations for future
returns were muted
so on that basis a couple of the key
assumptions
uh were taken down and reduced and i
think you all know the fed has
indicated that zero interest is their
target for the foreseeable future
and i think we just saw that the most
recent year was around one point four
percent
um so and we're at two now so um
you know we're seeing what we're
expecting to see in that regard
um so uh that's what happened in terms
of the analysis
and then in terms of the why while the
trustees are fiduciaries and they're
subject to the constitutional legal
requirements of
of the new hampshire constitution and
100a to determine
contribution rates by sound actuarial
evaluation and practice
and act solely in the interest of the
plan participants and the beneficiaries
so the trustees in fact were making the
decisions that they're
legally required make
slide
so the primary drivers i think we've
covered this but the assumed rate of
return is almost always
the the biggest impact in terms of
contribution rates and that was reduced
uh by a half of a percent from seven and
a quarter to six seven five
um we adopted updated post retirement
mortality assumptions as we just
discussed people are living longer
but that increases the cost of the plan
because obviously benefits have to be
paid out
for longer periods of time than
anticipated and the payroll growth
factor also
um has been one that we've been trying
to catch up to
employment growth just hasn't been
growing at the uh the rate
as expected uh compensation hasn't been
growing as the rate
has been expected and that's been a
particular problem with teachers because
as you all know
a number of pupils in the state has been
diminishing over time
and although it's not a one-to-one
relationship that means the number of
teachers has been decreasing as well
additional influences on the rates
although these are far more modest the
the cola that was passed uh and which
we're now paying out
had had a marginal impact because it was
agreed that it would be funded by future
contributions
and then also layered amortization has a
minor impact
um and that's sort of a mitigating
impact but because we're only in the
first layer here
that impact was somewhat nominal that
will increase over time
in terms of muting the impact of any
particular economic cycle
on on contribution rates
so this slide i think gives you the
graphic of
where we are with regard to contribution
rates and just to keep it simple
we've got all the member categories on
the left but if we just take
state employees which is the the top
line going across
you can see the pension normal cost 2.58
that's the actual cost of the benefit
itself
in terms of what state employees will
receive for a benefit what would that
cost
2.58 of the employer contribution rate
is what's there um
then next to it you can see the unfunded
liability
uh the unfunded liability is 11.17
percent of the total employer rate so
it's about
in the shaded column you can see within
that category it's 81
what's being paid by employers is going
to pay for that unfunded liability
that debt medical subsidy is about three
quarters of a percent
and when you add it up the total
employer rate right now is 14.53
so again you can see that the actual
cost of the benefit is nominal
as compared to the overall cost of
employers and that's why it's so
important to stay on the path
of extinguishing this unfunded liability
over time and into making the actuarial
adjustments that are required to
fund the plan properly as we go along
slide this slide is just intended to
give some
perspective or context for where new
hampshire stands relative
uh to the rest of the country so you can
see our data goes across the top line
this is a report
published by fitch and for the purpose
of doing this they equalize
all the investment plans by assuming
that their rate of return is six percent
so in other words uh they adjust
everybody's rate of return down to six
percent so we're all
it's apples to apples to my accounting
um you can see that as a percent
of personal income new hampshire's
adjusted net pension liability is 1.5
which ranks us 10th um
in in the country so um
that that's a very favorable place to be
a and that's lowest to highest so that's
that's a
obviously compared to uh you can see
we've identified
uh the new england states with us and
then the national average so we're well
below the national average
and you can see how we've compared to
states like connecticut massachusetts
where
the number is dramatically higher and
then when you look at pension
contributions
as a percent of direct general spending
by state and local governments we're at
3.91
and that basically puts us in the middle
of the pack
um so again this is um just
offered by way of context in terms of
taking a look at the bigger picture
um this graph i i think is um
there the next two graphs i'm going to
talk about for a minute because i think
they're very very important
um this is the assumed rate of return
discussion we had
you know iris earned assumed rate of
return is now
uh six point seven five percent but if
you go back to where we were in 2001 you
can see we're at nine
the blue bar that's below us that our
rate of return is the line going across
the page the bars going
north and south so to speak represent
what the average is
as published by the national association
of retirement system administrators
which is
nasra you'll probably come to hear that
term a lot
so you can see that we were being much
more optimistic than the national
average back then by almost a full point
and then over time what we've done is
we've adjusted our assumed rate of
return
and we've come down uh first eight and a
half then to seven and three quarters
then seven and a quarter and six and
three quarters
so now we're actually less than the
national average in terms of our assumed
rate of return
um the last time we adjusted when we
came down to seven and a quarter you can
see in 2015
we dropped down that seven and a quarter
uh put us
at below what the average was but you
can see the average caught back up to us
in
18 and now in 19
because we've adjusted again we've
dropped below so what that means is the
board over that period of time has taken
the steps to be conservative in its
views on the assumed rate of return and
has frankly been right the trend has
been coming down over time
and the board is making the adjustments
on a timely basis which is what the
board
i think is charged to do uh under the
law and by
fiduciary duty so they've done a very
good job there
next slide so
this line i think really tells um a very
positive story about what's happened
over the past 10 years in terms of
funding the plan the top line
is what our peers have done so if you go
back to 2010 the average
um funded ratio for
our peers was 77.1 so there's no doubt
we've had a funding problem
going back to the date when we
recognized what our true unfunded
liability was
you know following the recognition that
the actuarial methodology was
inappropriate
but over that time period you can see
that we've had a very gradual
but positive increase in our assumed
rate of return
even though we've taken steps excuse me
in our funded ratio
even though we've taken steps to reduce
our assumed rate of return
and as you all know when we when we make
reductions in our assumed rate of return
a funded ratio comes down because our
unfunded liability goes
up if you look at our peer group over
that period of time
their funded ratio has come down from
77.1 to 72
4. so it's been an improvement a
relatively modest one
while ours has gone up over that time
period so what that means is compared to
our peers
we've taken more positive steps to
improve our funded level
and so what was once a gap of about 19
percent
has come down dramatically so it's
closer to about nine percent
um the other thing i want to mention as
well is that
our current rate excuse me it's it's
60.8 it's
about 11 11.4 uh the other thing i want
to mention though is
had we not adjusted our assumed rate of
return this last time around
and left it where it was at seven and a
quarter uh seven and a quarter is about
the average right now for all those
other plans that are above us on that
line
our our uh funding ratio would have been
64.1
which would have made us even closer uh
to the average than we've ever been
before
so we have in fact been strengthening
the plan over that period of time
which i think is a very positive message
and it shows that the
plan that we have in place is in fact
working
and the board i think is meeting its um
responsibilities
one other footnote to this slide it's
not directly related to the slide but
you know the rating agencies take a look
at all public pension plans and they
comment on ours as well
and you know in new hampshire has very
strong financial position i think and i
think the rating agencies appreciate
that but one of the
things they always express some concern
about some more than others is
you know the funded ratio of the plan
and s p in their most recent report said
that
even though they expressed concern with
our funding level
the quote from them was we believe the
state's funding discipline including a
commitment to funding
at the full annual pension contribution
level that exceeds static funding levels
as likely to improve pension funding
trajectory over time
so you know this is something the rating
agencies look at and i think
um the actions of the board over this
period of time
have been positive in that respect
slide
so the key takeaways um you know the
board has got
legal and constitutional requirements
with recur with regard to the funding of
the plan and determining rates
the decisions were made at the last
experience study were necessary
to properly fund the plan over the long
term
the fact that employer contribution
rates
strengthen the plan that means that it
positions the plan better to withstand
to withstand economic downturns and it
also promotes intergenerational equity
which in plain english means that
by not kicking down kicking the can down
the road so to speak
um the people who are paying for the
benefits now and paying
as employers and members um are paying
in line with the benefit payout as
opposed to pushing the debt
further down for other people in the
future to pay off
one very important point i want to
mention is you know
these changes don't really change the
cost of the plans
only the timing of the payments the only
way they actually change the cost of the
plan as if
the changes aren't made on a timely
basis that does in effect
increase the unfunded liability over and
above what it would otherwise be
so it really is very much i won't call
it a game but it very much is a case of
paying me now or pay me later and
you know one thing that we've seen
historically is that pay me later
is a is a very bad place to be so
i think that's a very important message
for the committee
um that's uh i'm going to be handing it
back over to marty
here um and before i do i'm happy to
take any questions
i don't see any specific questions so uh
marty you can finish up okay
thank you madam chair um we are close to
the end i'm sure folks are getting a
little bit hungry
a couple of slides on legislation uh
just sort of wrap
up what's been going on uh last year
there were 13 bills related to the
retirement system introduced
all of which i think all the house bills
went through edna
nothing was enacted last year which is a
fairly
rare occurrence a couple of bills did
pass through the house and died in the
senate omnibus bills that the governor
vetoed
last fall because of coven this year so
far we've seen nine lsrs
posted related to the retirement system
seven
in the house and two in the senate um
many of the house lsrs have one or more
sponsors on this committee
uh some couple of them are repeat bills
from last year and or from prior
sessions
so you've got a good base of knowledge
on that everything
i've seen except one is going to edna
this year one other bill that that the
committee saw in 18 was assigned to
education this year
um and i'll follow that over there um
since 2007 and again i was
talking about that as sort of the
beginning of the beginning in terms of
uh
getting nhrs short up moving forward
there's been over 100 changes to the
plan
through legislation since then um some
significant like the contribution
rates the state subsidy um things like
that and others that are fairly minor or
administrative or
affect a small pool of people but
cumulatively you've kept
us busy i guess is the takeaway there um
and just just to clarify for the newer
members you know our our role in nhrs
staff is to provide you with data and
objective analysis either internal or
prepared by our actuary
uh we do that by submitting fiscal note
worksheets to lba
uh for them uh to put with the bills uh
we do something called bill briefs which
are handouts on
more complicated bills or bills that
have a history so you've got some
information at your fingertips
we we testify on most bills not in
support or
against but just for informational
purposes um
and then the informational materials
that we can provide uh as needed
annual reports etc so so we really try
to be you know
switzerland in a sense we uh don't want
to take a position
on matters that are left to the
legislature completely that basically
planted
um settler functions um you know you you
folks
decide when people can retire and how
much they're going to pay and how long
they have to work and all that kind of
stuff so
we're going to give you the numbers so
you can make a you know a reasoned
decision based on facts
and not sort of put our thumb on the
scale the only time
nhrs does take a position on legislation
is when the board feels that
legislation may intrude on their
fiduciary
duties or maybe constitutional or
internal revenue code
uh problematic with those um documents
so
again um we are kind of heading to the
end but we'll go one last slide for
george
to um bring it all home but if anybody
has any questions about legislative
matters
i'm glad to take them now
don't see any
thank you marty so i i'll just wrap up
quickly and then i'll just give you a
very quick update on where we are
on the executive director search so
a concluding message is that i think as
you've seen
the retirement system provides a
relatively modest pension benefit
um and those benefits that get paid 80
of them do remain in state in terms of
the local economy um there is a plan in
place to pay down the unfunded liability
and to manage future viability i
i think it's a good plan it's worked
well and
and the charts i provided that we looked
at i think
show that we are in fact on the path
and now that we're 10 years into that
amortization schedule
because there's a crossover point um we
should actually should be seeing more
and more progress
in terms of improving the funded ratio
as compared to what's happened over the
past 10 years
the board has been acting in a fiduciary
manner and taking the proper steps to
assure proper planned funding
and that's reflected in the decisions
they've made with the guide to the
assumed greater return over the 10 years
and as indicated the improvement in the
funded ratio
relative to our peers despite the impact
of those reductions on
the funded ratio and finally you know my
comment earlier
uh those of you who have been around for
the last nine years have heard me say on
more than one occasion that it is a
movie and it's not a slide or
one frame um you can say it's a marathon
and not a sprint
um there aren't any shortcuts and we all
have we always have to be careful about
snapshots because they prevent you know
they present
a very narrow slice of what the bigger
picture is and what's important is how
we do over time
and uh i think the last 10 years have
shown that we're making good progress
and
although i'm not going to be here to see
it i am retiring uh
at the end of february i'm hopeful that
um
we'll be able to stay on the plan for
the next 20 years and achieve that
objective
um so the last thing i want to say is um
i i have been with the system for nine
years it's been an honor and privilege
uh to work with the folks at the
retirement system and just
and to serve the state in that regard uh
i'm proud of the progress we've made
it's been
very certainly been very interesting and
challenging experience over that period
of time
we're uh pretty deep into the search now
for a replacement
in fact we have a meeting this afternoon
with the personnel committee for a
couple of hours to review
a short list of candidates that we have
from
all across the country so we're making
good progress and um
we expect to be able to come to a
decision in the very near term
so i thank you for all your service and
i'm happy to take any questions
i have a question yes representative
scitec
what are you gonna do in retirement
what am i gonna do tbd i tried to retire
once about
12 years ago and i failed so i'm just
going to see if i can do better at it
this time
the jury is out though thanks
hey representative lancas uh yes thank
you for the presentations
if uh one of us has any questions you
know clarifications on this
um you know who would it be best to
contact and what's the contact info
why don't you come directly into marty
and marty can tell you uh the best way
to do that
and and my contact information is on the
email that pam will be forwarding to you
uh with with links to some of the
informational documents
all right thank you yeah and that should
be in your email
box right now
thanks madam chair i just wanted to wish
george uh
good luck with your attempted retirement
this time and
we'll see you later in the session marty
thank you
all right thank you all for for uh being
here
yes how clearly you hear me now
am i excellent much better i don't know
what changed
uh because i'll i'll try again tomorrow
or later this afternoon i guess thank
you
all right we are breaking for lunch we
will resume
at one o'clock with a short
talk on the office of professional
licensure and certification
please close your cameras and pam will
be sharing
a her screen with a notice that says
that
all right thank you thanks again thank
you all
see you george thank you thank you
bye-bye
question carol yes um
are we just are we supposed to be
leaving this link open for the
for the one o'clock return just is that
what i'm getting from that
we just leave it you can leave it open
or you can
uh re-link whichever is more convenient
for you
gotcha okay great thank you
hello
wow everybody is so proud
i will admit i'm still eating my lunch
so i'm gonna block myself
i like that we can still participate
and take care of ourselves in the
appropriate ways
foreign
questions
okay it's one o'clock
nice view steve welcome back to our
orientation
this afternoon we're going to hear a bit
from the office of professional
licensure and certification
which we have a lot of dealings with and
the director
lindsey kourtney is
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee um thank you for the
opportunity to
appear before you today to discuss a
little bit about
what our office um does and what we've
been working on
over the last um year or so
i do have a powerpoint
if i can share my screen
and and if you would please send us
a copy of this presentation we'd very
much appreciate it
of course of course happy to do that is
everyone can
can um can you see those slides
excellent excellent alrighty so
um just by way of background oplc is a
very uh fairly new
agency to the state of new hampshire was
formed in 2015 under governor hassan
um prior to its creation we had
the majority of the technical licensing
boards had been previously consolidated
with the joint boards as you may recall
several of our health licensing boards
were administratively attached to the
department of health and human services
and then several boards operated
independently so with
hb2 the licensing boards the majority of
the licensing boards were consolidated
into the office of professional
licensure
and certification um with that obviously
our positions and systems and funding
transferred from other state
boards and agencies um to the office
the purpose is really set forth in rsa
310a
which is to promote efficiency and
economy in the administration of the
professional licensing boards
i think what's important to note is that
the purpose of the agency is not
necessarily the purpose of the licensing
boards the licensing boards all retain
their own
individual regulatory or authority over
the
professions that they regulate and
license
the office's goal is really to just
promote the efficiency
in in the process
so um a couple of highlights i wanted to
make note of we currently have 54
licensing boards that we administer as
well as the prescription drug monitoring
program
at present we have a little over 300
board members
the majority of them receive some sort
of per diem although it's not
consistent something that we're trying
to remedy through statutory change
and some of them also receive mileage
reimbursement beyond
that they're essentially volunteers most
of whom are appointed by gnc
some are appointed directly by me and
some others
are nominated by various professional
associations
so with the exception of the pdmp which
is its own little silo as i'm sure you
know
our staff at the office primarily
assists the boards with
two functions the first obviously is
licensing individuals who wish to
practice a particular profession in new
hampshire
and the second is really enforcing
compliance through laws and
investigations so we've got licensing
and we've got enforcement
a couple of fun facts in fiscal year 20
we had over 223 000
occupational licenses in new hampshire
that were active
this was a substantial increase from the
prior fiscal year of about 29 percent
um it's really unclear at this point
what caused such a such an increase in
the number of licensees
the board of nursing has bears the bulk
of our licensees
and it could be that we're seeing an
increase of licensees through the board
of nursing
in fiscal year 20 um we cataloged about
1100 complaints i'm not actually
um confident that that number is
accurate and you'll and
and as we talk a little bit further um
about our reorganization i'll explain
why but essentially we have since
consolidated
um the investigations and complaint
process
and realized that we were not um
counting all of the
complaints and not all the boards were
keeping track of of the complaints as
required so we
really think that the the number that
we're going to see in fiscal year 21 is
closer to about 3 000 inspections and
investigations
so in fiscal year 20 we had 67 permanent
classified positions
um we had reorganized we're working on
reorganizing the agency so about 17
full-time positions are dedicated to
enforcement related tasks
inspections and investigations
prosecutors
um 39 full-time positions are dedicated
to licensing and ministering boards
um and about 20 of oplc's workforce part
time
i can tell you from my observation that
that in and of itself is a barrier to
achieving efficiency in economy and that
there has been
a constant churn of personnel at oplc
related to its part-time workforce
people generally utilize the part-time
positions to move into other full-time
positions throughout the state
we have seen a decrease in that
obviously because of the hiring freeze
so we've had some consistency there but
that is something that we're seeking to
hopefully resolve as we move forward
we are a self-funded agency and and
obviously our fees have to bear
a relationship and approximate the
expense of issuing the license of
inspecting and regulating the businesses
licensed we've had some
different approaches with our fees i
think initially we're general funded
although
that that predates me and then we moved
to a dedicated fund
that was non-lapsing um and then
now we have a dedicated fund that lastes
at the end of every fiscal year
um which from my perspective you know
can can be
problematic in trying to meet the the
needs of the agency
because we administer over 54 licensing
boards each with their own professional
um regulatory authority we obviously
engage in a lot of
rule making and in 2018 we comprise 20
of the state's rulemaking proposals
which is quite significant in an agency
of our size
relatively small about 86 staffers
um to to accomplish 20 percent of the
state's rulemaking proposals
so we really are right now engaged
in a process to really rethink uh the
purpose of the agency the mission of the
agency and the vision of the agency
um i think many of you can recall when
oplc was formed
it's been quite a rocky start since
2015.
and um the agency itself
really never came into its own it really
in my opinion
took on um a lot of the you know the
board's
mission which i think is distinct from
the agency mission so we're currently
undergoing a review of our mission and
our visions
but i think at a minimum occupational
licensing has to protect the public
obviously
by ensuring that individuals meet
minimum standards necessary to practice
in a safe manner
at the same time we need to make sure
that those
standards those regulations are not so
um
out of touch that they they
they represent um an unnecessary barrier
to workforce entry so licensing in of
itself
has to be a barrier to workforce entry
um but we don't want to create
unnecessary barriers and i think that's
one purpose of the agency that's
distinct from
from licensing boards so let's uh
i didn't create this but i i like it
it's
it's a nice visual of how we all come
together
so when oplc was first created
this was the basic org chart in that in
rsa 310a
we have two divisions we have a division
of health professions a division of
technical professions
we technically don't have a division of
administration
um but administration is overseen by the
oplc executive director
and when oplc was hold on
first formed so we had
um 20 boards within the division of
technical professions you'll see them
noted here
and the staff really mirrored what it
looked like with the joint boards and
this existed
you'll see until july of 2020 um
there really had been no major changes
to to the staff that were supporting the
licensing boards
um the division of health professions
boards obviously mainly health
professions we've
added a few throughout the years most
recently veterinary medicine
um and you'll see that the staff
um again through july 2020
really just mirrored what the boards had
for existing staff when they came over
to oplc
in 2015 so if i um
kind of scroll in you know this was
pharmacy
um then we had nursing cosmetology
there really had been no integration
that one would expect
for for agency and what our purposes
so um really
in this past year we've engaged in an
initiative
to achieve our statutory mission through
agents um
to achieve our statutory mission of
achieving efficiencies through agency
reorganization
um so you can see in fy 2021 we had the
division of health professions and
division of technical professions and
each
um board and the staff that supported
those boards had their own process
for doing pretty much everything that
our agency
was was accomplishing so we had between
all of the boards 54 different ways of
taking in mail
54 different ways of approaching
customer service
54 different licensing processes and 54
different investigation processes
this obviously is not efficient and was
not the intended purpose
of the agency um and so
what we have been doing over the last uh
six to eight months
is going through an agency restructuring
and we are requesting some statutory
changes to make this complete
um to really align agency in accordance
with
job function and not subject matter from
my perspective our staff accomplished
two primary functions licensing and
enforcement and so we should really be
focusing on processes
and not subject matter so we'd like to
create the division of licensing and
board administration
and the division of enforcement and
really
get down to one male process that's
already been accomplished one customer
service approach
that's part of our next phase one
licensing process and one investigation
process
um where we're at with that right now is
that we have created
a division of enforcement or without the
actual statutory change of the division
but we've we've put the people together
and they are functioning
as one unit um we have put together
one um specific mail process and we're
moving on next to a customer service
unit
so um i spoke a little bit obviously
about our agency reorganization project
but i think the
other thing is we need to leverage
technology in order to achieve
efficiency
so um we've embarked on an online
licensing initiative
um many of our boards have some version
of online licensing through our my
licensing online portal
um not all are online and not all
require online
renewals in particular and i this really
um is inefficient
and increases the amount of time that it
takes to get somebody licensed
which then results in a barrier to
workforce entry because
at the end of the day what i'm seeing
across the state is that we're really
competing with other states particularly
vermont
um really vermont they're very they're
very fast and processing licenses so if
somebody comes in
and they're looking for um they may be
on the border and they're looking for a
job if it takes new hampshire
you know six weeks to accomplish what it
takes vermont
24 hours to do then obviously we're not
we're not going to
obtain that licensed professional um to
provide workforce for us
so in any event we need to move from my
perspective
on to electronic licensing and so
we've started on an initiative all of
our renewals will be up
online by march 15th
and then we will slowly work toward
getting all initial licensing
applications online
we also need to improve communications
um
and our website has historically not
been great
at all um it's been very difficult i
think for the end user to really
um understand uh basically what it takes
to obtain a license and also to file a
complaint so we
um are we completely redesigned our
website and i
just prior to this meeting saw saw a
draft and it should be launched by
february
1st of 2021 it's a complete redesign
focusing
on improved communication to licensees
and then also document management
scanning all documentation
to reduce error rates and making sure
that we're leveraging technology that
way
we are also working on achieving
efficiency in accounting
we are moving to eliminate our double
accounting method
um which which you may see when it comes
up um during the budget bill but
uh essentially this this uh was
this was not transparent in my opinion
um
it required some explanation as to what
was actually going on with their
finances and so to increase public
transparency
we want to eliminate the double
accounting method um
the other thing that we're looking at is
you know when oplc was first formed we
were tracking everything down we had
different
activity codes for all the boards that's
incredibly inefficient
so we needed to start functioning as an
agency as opposed to
um 54 different boards and so we're
looking at
possibly eliminating the activity codes
obviously we'd still be able to track
expenses and revenue to the board level
but just the actual process of having
everything broken up by activity codes i
think will assist
and then finally we're looking at
achieving efficiency and personnel
um one of the things we're looking at as
i said earlier
20 of our workforce is part time this is
this is a problem this is a barrier to
achieving efficiency
and so as we move forward we'd really
like to utilize some
funding that has been historically a
class 50 funding
um to create full-time positions and
hopefully that will provide us the
consistency we need in workforce
um spoke a little bit about leveraging
technology some of the things some of
the projects that we're looking into
include investigations and inspection
software
when i first i came on board about a
year ago
we had one
person functioning in a prosecutor role
outside of the apu
and he he is an attorney but he wasn't
in an attorney position
um so we've completely created an
in-house
prosecutions unit and investigations
unit that's really going to decrease the
amount of time
to get a case process through our agency
um when i came on board cases were
lagging for
years which is really unacceptable so
i've given
my staff the directive that we need to
reduce that to
complaint to adjudication in eight
months or less
and i think it's going to help um by
leveraging technology so we're we'd like
to focus on
moving to electronic operations that way
the other thing that we're working on is
obviously our fees so there's been some
um there's been some back and forth i
think regarding fees in terms of what
are
what our statutory authority is and um
what the board statutory authority is so
historically as you may recall
all the boards set their fees a number
of our boards have fees set in
statute um the majority of other fees
are set in rule
then in 2018 rsa 310a was amended to
give oplc the authority to set the fees
but the board still retained those fees
um
or that authority in their practice act
so um
our position in consulting with doj is
that we
did not necessarily have the authority
to set fees for all the boards
um and so we are seeking some statutory
changes on that
and i'm assuming that at some point will
come
before you
but um essentially we're projecting
revenue
um fy 22 and 23 you'll see it reflected
there
we are anticipated to lapse a certain
amount of funding
um of course every year
and you'll see with our you'll see
you know you'll see the confusion
because the agency was previously
self-billing itself so
the numbers appear to be a little
inflated in terms of our revenue for fy
2020 15.1
and then obviously what what um we're
anticipating
for fy 22 and 23. so by eliminating the
double accounting it makes clear that
um that you know what our revenue and
expenses actually
are and so
then in terms of priorities we are
um first thing is you know we're
undergoing a performance audit
that um i actually had the entrance
meeting today
um we are completing our move projects
um some of you may know but that we were
uh asked to move from our philbrick uh
building location we did that quite
expeditiously in about 30 days
over july during covid and during our
restructuring so um
it was a little it was a little
difficult it was fun um but we are now
relocating at seven eagles square
and so we have a couple of projects that
we need to complete in order to
to make that happen um we're working on
creating and implementing standardized
procedures so as i
previously mentioned the agency really
hadn't done much
by way of standardizing procedures so
the agency really is starting to
exercise its authority to
um to do the adjusting licensing fees
fees have to be adjusted um
some of the boards are at you know 250
percent some are at nine percent
you know so we really need to adjust
those fees but i think we we
certainly need a statutory change in
order to do that
um we would like to redefine our mission
and vision again
i don't i i don't think it's just
protecting the public
protecting the public is obviously the
board's mission and we have to
administer and facilitate that but we
need to do that in an efficient and
economic way
um which has impact on workforce
again we'd like to move all licensing
online eliminating paper
um completing our agency restructuring
i'm hoping that to be completed within
the next six months i had a meeting with
dop
today about that and we're hoping to
complete that over the next six months
and then finally you know the agency is
really interested in looking at all the
requirements uh for licensure
and eliminating those requirements that
are not absolutely necessary to ensure
minimum standards are satisfied
we're doing this with the boards of
course um but one of the prime examples
that i'll give you is a photograph i
don't know why we require a photograph
um seems like there's some room for for
bias there
and that's just a prime example but
there are others for sure and so as we
get deeper into
our licensing projects we are going to
be taking a look at that
um finally what i didn't mention was our
prescription drug monitoring program
this obviously as you know is a separate
it's a separate program that
is a it's a tool for providers and
dispensers to utilize to determine
um when they're dispensing or
prescribing controlled medications to
assess
whether or not that prescription is
appropriate there has been a lot of
conversation at the state level as you
probably know
about what the overall purpose of the
pdmp
is it was originally i think intended to
be a provider tool
but as we've moved forward i think
there's
there's a desire obviously to access the
data
for public health purposes and so
there's a conversation taking place
regarding
what pdmp's role if any
is in public health i think the state
probably needs to make a decision on
that i think if it
i think if pdmp is viewed as a public
health tool
pdp probably does not belong at oplc
to be frankly um to speak frankly i mean
we deal with licensing if it is a
provider tool then
then it is appropriately um
housed at uh oplc so i think some
conversations
you know need to be had regarding the
purpose of the pdmp
and that's that's it i apologize i kind
of went through that quickly and threw a
lot of information at you but i'm happy
to answer any questions about
what our agency does what we're working
on what our goals are
um if there's anything else i can
provide please please don't hesitate
and i'll just interject quickly that i
sent the lindsay's presentation to all
of you at about 11 o'clock this morning
using
along with the retirement systems um
presentation
and the subcommittee list so i i use the
you know the house edna
addresses and if you know you should you
should have that
in your mailboxes
are there any questions
all got hit by the fire hose
with me all right representative
your audio cut out on me yeah thank you
madam chair
um my question goes in looking at the
restructuring of
the office um being around for a little
while
and watching as this legislation was
passed and
uh going forward
it was my understanding we were just
going to combine some of the
functions and reduce duplication
for numerous boards this
now seems like it's a whole total revamp
of the boards under the executive
director of oplc
and case in point is
looking at investigations or
if there's any complaints going forward
with
any of the boards that is going to go to
a centralized
hearing process versus going to each
individual board
could you just let me know if i'm
correct on that going forward and
if so what is
the reaction from these boards and not
being able to do the hearings themselves
as individual boards with their members
yeah no thank you representative i
appreciate the question so
um to get into the nitty-gritty of what
we're doing with complaints is that we
actually worked with all boards to have
them issue standing orders
so they've all consented to this process
those that are participating
what we were finding is that
[Music]
all of the complaints were originally
going to board administrators
and there was not a specific standard as
to what they were supposed to be doing
with those complaints
some um sent letters to licensees some
gave them to the boards
some put them in a file drawer to be
frank
um some you know it just was not
protective of the public which is the
board's mission
and so the boards have overwhelmingly
been supportive of this idea that the
complaint is now going to
go to trained um enforcement
um staff members who are going to take a
look at the complaint assess whether or
not it is an emergency or not
if so notify the board so we can have an
emergency meeting
um if not then then everything is going
to be treated the same in terms of the
licensee gets a letter
the licensee responds if records are
needed
um then they will get it you know then
we'll get the records
then we'll do a memo to the board saying
this is what
is in the complaint would you like to
proceed with formal investigation and if
so an order of formal investigation will
ensue
then an investigator will be appointed
to work with either
a recruits board member or you know an
investigator
and then it goes back to the board with
a report of investigation and the board
makes the decision about whether to
proceed to discipline
at all times the board is fully acting
in an adjudicatory role
i i think though that your question
raises a very good
point in that what we're finding with
the office
and we've contracted with clear the
council on licensure
enforcement and i forget the acronym but
in any event
um you know they're doing an analysis
for us as well
i i don't think that there's a consensus
in the state
about what the purpose of the office is
um and i think that has led to some some
some issues right in terms of you know
are we um and i know others have told me
that we're supposed to just be paying
rent
or are we really supposed to be ensuring
efficiency and what does that
look like um i think that question has
to be answered in order for the office
to be
successful i can tell you that
around 23 other states have umbrella
agencies
and um at least the four that were
surveyed as part of our
analysis through clear and it's a draft
form and i can provide that to you once
it's completed
um i have not observed the similar
issues in other states regarding this
this you know um talking poll with
regard to authority
i think in order for us to get where we
need to be in terms of
appropriately protecting the public and
also ensuring that their regulations
are sufficient to meet minimum standards
there has to be oversight
and what we were seeing with uh with
with what was handled what was going on
with complaints
is that um and that's just a microcosm
of the issue in general
is that there were complaints that were
not being adjudicated for years
one year two year three years that's
really unacceptable from a public
protection standpoint it's also not fair
for the licensee who needs to get back
to work and not have this hanging over
their heads
and so i think providing that oversight
and really assisting um the boards
administer those reducing the time
frames is our
is our end goal but i agree with you
representative i think
i think there are some questions out
there that need to be answered in terms
of what our overall
goal is because my goal it doesn't
always line up with with
maybe what others believe it it should
be
thank you and i think uh the performance
audit will help but
also going forward and seeing what that
comes out is
representative roy
thank you madam chairman uh thank you
for taking my question
so um just uh from an experi
experience standpoint i was actually an
investigator for the massachusetts
border registration and medicine
and it's a very very complex field to
investigate
and it takes a very specific skill set
and a very specific background knowledge
in medicine frankly and we had
investigators we had nurse investigators
and we had attorneys
all assigned to that i cannot imagine
a person who has that skill set also
being able to do a thorough
investigation into
building inspectors or home inspectors
how is it that we're going to be able to
coalesce all this into one without
actually letting the public down because
we're not able to do a thorough
investigation because of the
specific background needed by these
people
yeah that's a great question um so what
we've done is we've collaborated with
the boards the boards were previously
and i say i'm talking generally but
every board had
their own process which was which was
precisely the problem
um but the large majority of boards
were recusing board members or they had
members of a subcommittee
in that field and they were asked to go
out and do all the interviews and get
all the records and
um you know push the paper around
and so what i think is appropriate and
we also have a physician
um that we contract with we also have
nurses on staff
um we have a medical review subcommittee
comprised solely of physicians that we
work with
but i think it's very important that we
utilize our experts for their expertise
but it's not really fair in my opinion
to ask them to go do all that
administrative work
so the process that we've proposed that
we're working with the boards on
is that we pair up an action you know a
professional investigator
um with the experts and they can work
together in putting that report of
investigation
together because i agree and not all
cases are quality of care cases some of
them
you know it's patently obvious that
there could be gross negligence
but there are cases that do many cases
that require that level of expertise
but i think we need to be utilizing them
for their expertise
and then we can promote people wanting
to volunteer and participate in the
process because that's another issue we
have is recruiting members
um and so i hope that answers your
question i i fully agree with you and i
think that we need to be
utilizing uh the expertise of those uh
who are plainly volunteering their their
precious
time to to assist with public safety
follow up madam chair follow up yeah i
guess you kind of touched on the answer
i'm looking for um
so for let me just give you an example
in the medicine field
um you've got a couple primary issues
and standard of care usually isn't with
the biggest one you're going to have
over prescribing
you're going to have inappropriate
conduct um with with patients
and in those fields
just doing the investigation you have to
know what you're looking for
so sending out a generally trained
investigator
to take statements you're going to miss
a lot of things so that's that's
so like what we used to do is we had a
nurse an investigator an attorney signed
to each case
now i know you don't have the money to
do that but that shows you the level of
intricacy involved in investigating a
medicine case
versus some of the other i mean all the
different boards you have in speciality
so that's what my concern is if we just
kind of say okay everybody's an
investigator for everything
um you know the old saying about jack of
all trades
you know i agree with you representative
and i think i could spend a whole
you know hour too long presentation and
you know
dialogue regarding our investigation
process because it's the first thing
that we worked on
um my i my goal is to get to a point
where we have an attorney a nurse or
whomever it is assigned to every case
obviously there are budgetary issues
which maybe i you know i get my
general court to help us out with um i
come from background of private practice
where i did male practice work so that
was our
um that was our model when i was in
private practice
um so the way we've gotten the way we've
we've worked within our resources now is
to really
leverage um the volunteer experience we
have so we do have attorneys in the
office that drive
that work with our um our professional
investigator
who has um experience in in a particular
different fields who also works with the
assigned either physician
or um other you know experts
um to to determine how an investigation
should proceed
well just a follow-up comment madam
chair um well if
if this legislation that's going to
enable all this is going to come before
us this year i would suggest you to
bring that
hour and a half presentation because i'm
going to want to hear all of it
thank you absolutely
thank you uh before schuett
thank you madam chair hi miss courtney
nice to see you
my my original idea was
similar to representative goalie
and roy's concerns that
with the diversity of boards i'm not
sure that
a one-size-fits-all approach
is going to be appropriate so we will be
looking at that closely
my question specifically though was
mentioned the performance audit did i
hear you say that you were having the
oh session on that today
no we had an entrance meeting so it's
just the kickoff
uh the kickoff meeting was today i said
we um
yeah so it's just beginning
correct correct okay thank you you're
welcome that was my question
we will be getting that performance
audit once it is complete
no doubt about it right i just was
curious about
what kind of time frame we were looking
at
uh probably before the end of june i'd
say but not that much
yeah if they're just starting that's
what i'm thinking i just like i said
wanted to see where they were
okay representative schmidt
thank you madam chair um and
uh i'd like to uh associate myself with
the remarks of the previous questioners
on the committee
uh some of us have been at this uh for a
long time
and we are confronted by
a lot of issues first of all there are
multiple boards
uh that have come in at different
times some have been licensed for you
know
decades or even more than a century
others have been licensed
you know very recently and
it is kind of a hodgepodge for sure
and so some degree of standardization is
not something i would oppose
uh and and uh and an attempt to
reorganize as something that i also
think
is necessary because the the whole
concept was
put together and i first of all need to
to uh
make sure you understand i i've been on
the committee now for 15 years
um so and we have been dealing with
uh this entire process uh in
in fits and starts uh during that entire
period
without ever really having that much of
a handle on what was going behind
on behind the high wall um
we would sometimes hear complaints uh
about
administrators or administrative
procedures and so forth and so on
all without having much access to the
facts
uh for quite a while but also not
necessarily having any experience in
management
i don't have any management background
to speak of
and i don't profess to you know be able
to
come in there and with a clean broom and
and
and clean house uh but there it is clear
that that when the
oplc was conceived of and created
that it was intended to reduce
redundancy and
in enhanced efficiency and so forth and
so on
um another thing i'd like to reference
here
uh is that um although
the the boards most of the boards are
boards uh and were intended to
uh to you know make the
the the professions and the pr and the
occupations
pay for their own administration i think
that's
not an unreasonable premise
but that they were not intended to be
cash cows
for uh for the general fund
but that they were in some cases
by accident or just perhaps on purpose
turned into cash cows and and that i
totally opposed and i think
i speak for most of my you know
experienced colleagues in that
regard that we certainly do not want to
leave fees at levels that produce
extra revenues for the state how does
however desperately the state may need
extra revenue
that's not the way to get them by using
the professions
as no levers or
as knee breakers effectively because you
got to pay or
you don't get to play so
it's clear that that this whole process
is a very complex uh and
and and also to some degree very
entrenched
and redoing it will be difficult uh
but one of the things that it seems to
me that is necessary
is or would be advantageous is if we
are looking at what some other states
are doing so that we are not
inventing the wheel entirely on our own
it seems to me like you're going at this
with a lot of
zeal and a lot of
elbow grease but but
the question is whether we have the
necessary management
expertise to and whether it really makes
sense for us to
invent the wheel here uh in an attempt
to get to
something that protects the public you
reference that several times in your
testimony
uh to in to protect the public but also
to uh promote and protect the trades and
professions
uh that's all an important function
you reference pdmp and i didn't hear you
say
that uh that one of the functions was
to prevent you know illegal
acquisition and use of
of various different medications by
people who are
not in fact ill or needing medication at
all but who are
operators who are attempting to you know
get uh illicit uh
drugs in their into their hands
for sales and so forth and so on and it
was a monitoring program
uh and i didn't hear you say that so
i think that's possibly the most
important driver
of the creation of the what was
originally the pmp and then became pdmp
um but anyway so i
but i've been involved in a lot of these
processes and
i i i've come to recognize that
that there's a great deal of expertise
in the boards
that is an important ingredient of the
whole thing
so one of my questions is how much
resistance are you getting from the
boards that seems to be
inappropriate as opposed to appropriate
yeah thank you for that for that
question um
just just to step back a little bit we
are looking at what other states are
doing through clear
and i anticipate having a final report
soon
um but we contracted with clear to do an
overall analysis
um again as i mentioned 23 states i have
a similar umbrella agency so we
i agree we shouldn't reinvent the wheel
and we um
we shouldn't we're not going at this
blindly um a lot of them have a similar
structure to oplc
and the ones that were interviewed do
not have the same issues
that new hampshire has in terms of this
this question about what is the purpose
of an umbrella agency um
and the authority of the boards versus
the agency um
in fact when i was when i was speaking
with our consultants at clear
a lot of the other states were even
offended by the question
um and i think part of that has to do
with the fact that
the agencies have existed for a lot
longer than new hampshire
um and i think part of it has to do with
the fact that
there hasn't been a clear pathway for
oplc
as an agency both in strategy but also
you know
in statute so um so that's the first
part of it i'm really looking forward to
seeing that final report because i think
that'll provide us with some good
um talking points and and for ways for
us to make some decisions
um you know the second piece of that is
how are the boards feeling
um i fully believe in collaboration
um unfortunately that takes a lot longer
and
um i think agents i think oplc has been
in crisis for about five years
and since its inception as we've seen
with that with the
constant turnover for executive
management
um the issues within the agency and i
have a lot of
opinions as to why that is um it's not
really an operating environment uh
that anybody really wants to work on so
we're trying to address that in an
expeditious manner
um but i think a lot of the boards in
collaborating with them
um they have gotten on board because
they have also
been tired of of the issues that um
that we've had we've had to deal with
and i'll give you that example for
for our enforcement unit um we had been
sending
the majority of our cases over to the
attorney general's office and the
administrative prosecutions unit we
obviously have
um we have an agreement with them um and
we fully fund their apu
and um we started to see some
some resource issues um and obviously
cases were lagging at two or three years
which is completely unacceptable
um and so we said we there needs to be
more oversight and the boards are
fully agree in agreement with that so we
created this new
structure in-house where we are
accountable we are providing oversight
um if cases are taking on too long i can
go down to my staff and say what is
going on you need to prioritize this
this is a problem
and there's that accountability and the
boards are seeing that
and all of them agreed through a
standing order the ones you know the
ones that we're bringing on board i
think mental health is the last one
um they've all done this voluntarily
through collaboration
so we may not all always agree regarding
um you know the process but we've gotten
to a point where i think we've developed
good relationships with the majority of
them that they're willing to try
something new
because what we've been doing hasn't
been working what the boards were doing
i don't think had been working
um because these are full-time
professionals who for the most part
are are working in the field and
and they don't have time to devote to
constant continued improvement for
process improvement
so i hope that answers your question
representative um
collaboration i i think this committee
has reference has has
certainly manifested a considerable
interest in helping the
agency to work effectively and
efficiently
but also we've had a lot of concerns
because
there are a number of this is always
although we have a number of new members
this time around we also have a majority
the committee has been around
for quite a while been in the
legislature for quite a while been on
this committee for quite a while
and thus has seen the so-called
evolution
of the agency from you know the old the
old days of the
joint board and order mental health
practice and all the other boards
uh to what we're seeing today and has a
lot of concerns but also a lot of
dedication to trying
and assist uh this entity
in functioning uh effectively and
uh so we we i i can speak for myself
and i think i can speak for some of my
experienced colleagues that we
want to be involved in in
what what's what comes about here
uh and and to not we don't want to give
you blanket authority
for things that that that we have not
gotten a very good handle on reasons for
it
so thank you representatives i'll leave
it i'll leave it with that
for the moment but we do want to be very
closely involved
thank you representative fellows thank
you madam chair
um i have two questions the first one is
is there a report that will tell us how
many
um complaints are filed annually and
what those complaints are about the
different boards involved
and my second question is does the
public
and do employers have access to the
certification database to check on
the status of somebody's credentials
yes yes they're both so we have an
annual report that's required by statute
for us to be completed every
november 1. um that's posted on our
website and that has a list of the
complaints by boards
um what i will say though is
historically we relied on board
administrators who were fielding these
these complaints to keep track of the
complaints and i don't think it was an
accurate
data set and so that has been changed
going forward
with the consolidation of enforcement
efforts in one bureau
and what we've seen between september
and um
and uh the end of december we had about
650 complaints received which is about
double that what was previously reported
so i
i do not um think that that was an
accurate reflection
i think in our um our next annual report
it'll be about 3 000
as my anticipation um with respect to
your second question
yes we have a licensee look up tool so
if you go into i think it's new
newhamsterlicenses.nh.gov
you can type in somebody's name and
their credentials should be listed there
and if they have any disciplinary
history that should also be listed there
so just one follow-up if possible follow
up
thank you um you you mentioned earlier
that you thought it was not necessary to
have
photos i i would think that if you're
going to have a database where
somebody can look up for example to see
if a plumber
is licensed that it might be useful to
have a photo of that plumber also
yeah i think what we've seen with the
a question do episode agree um
i can see how that might be helpful but
one of the other things that i think we
need to think about and i'm not married
to anything but
um we need to think about a privacy and
b
um we need to think about potential bias
um
and one of the things that we've seen
with occupational licensing
is that when you're using humans using
humans to do anything
there are opportunities for implicit
bias i have personally seen it and i
won't comment
on particular boards or their operations
but so there is a movement
nationwide to eliminate those sort of
bias subjective requirements
and the photograph is one of them the
other thing is
you know if we're requiring a photograph
at every renewal from an efficiency
standpoint which we don't presently
require photographs that renew we
require them at initial licensing only
at some point somebody's photograph is
going to become completely outdated and
useless um so i think those are the
things that we need to think about and
again i'm not married to anything
but i i want the boards to be engaging
in this type of analysis this is what
i'd like to encourage them to do because
just because we've done something for 30
years doesn't mean it's the best way to
be doing it
i think new hampshire can eventually be
on the cutting edge of occupational
licensing and looking at what do we need
really need
to ensure minimum standards are
satisfied and then what is just extra
um that is a barrier to workforce
because we have seen that our current
licensing structure
is in a lot of ways a barrier to
workforce entry um we've seen that with
mental health
um and i think that if you didn't have
and now i'm on my soapbox but if you
didn't have
oplc as an agency we wouldn't for
example have been able to do
what the state did with regards to
emergency licensing it wouldn't have
happened
um and i think that's a benefit that
we've seen but we also saw through the
emergency licensing process
what sort of barriers we have in place
thank you representative pearson
okay
this this whole business about a photo
here okay if we're trying to verify
credentials of someone a photo is
is a part of that process we put a photo
on a driver's license
we put a photo on a passport this is not
a social experiment
this is a verification process
that someone's credentials match the
person that
you are either trying to bring in or
trying to
use it's not a privacy issue if i'm
trying to verify the credentials
of a licensed plumber and i'm doing that
let's just say
because i'm bringing this plumber into
my home to do work
that's not a privacy issue hardly this
it's a relationship issue for me to
verify that i'm
bringing someone in that has the
credentials that they claim they do
so i fully reject the idea that a photo
is somehow
a problem here as far as updating a
photo
every single one of us have shot a
zillion
very bad photos off of these things okay
we've taken more photographs in the last
year than the first hundred years of the
camera
so the idea that it would be difficult
for someone to update a photo
is just is just i don't buy it i mean
you can do that with a cell phone in
three seconds and
you know with the with the push for
continued advancements in technology
with oplc and you know you talk about
bringing
licensing up to a faster level well then
certainly a reapplication
and the ability to upload a photo should
be part of that
if if i may if i may madam chair
i mentioned the photo merely as an
opportunity that i think
boards need to engage in and questions
about what is actually required
i do not believe any state publishes
photographs of their licensees i'm a
licensed attorney
in two states there's not a photograph i
think one
one way to accomplish that goal right is
to ask for a driver's license and look
up
whether or not that's the actual person
on the license tool but again i don't
want to get sidetracked on whether photo
is great whether it's not
the point is that the boards are
engaging in this analysis which we
haven't been doing
that was really my intent regarding the
comment regarding the photograph
okay are there any other questions
okay i don't see any
well thank you all for your time i'm
happy to talk offline about anything
that i've talked about today
and any of our initiatives as we're
going forward and certainly the
legislation that i'm sure will come
before you as well
we've got a fair number of bills that
i'm sure you'll be involved with
absolutely thank you again
all right so thank you all for attending
i'm
wish we could have done this in person
because it's a lot more informative but
under the circumstances i think this is
about as good as we're going to get
tomorrow there's a briefing from
the governor's office or actually i
think it's the attorney general
uh on the emergency orders
pam could you talk to
sure there's a senior associated
attorney general jill perlow will be
coming in
to talk about the the law that
addresses states of emergency and
that's about it
so that we have a number of bills on
that this year and it's
very topical and after that uh
representative schmidt and i will give
a 30 000 foot briefing on the
administrative rule process
that i hope will not take too long i'm
trying to schedule hearings for next
week but i haven't
yet figured out or haven't been informed
of what days we can use
so i will i will let you know when i
know which will
who knows when that'll happen and thanks
again
any other questions or comments
i have a question madam chair surprise
schmidt thank you so i've heard
an interesting new pronunciation of one
of our colleagues names
today and i'm wondering if we could have
michael tell us how he pronounces his
last name because i don't
i have been pronouncing it differently
than you did and i
am very sensitive to linguistic things
so i'm wondering if we could have some
clarification about how to correctly
pronounce
pronouns representative what what i
thought it was yakubovic but
who knows you got it
that's correct okay
i will i will attempt to maintain that
thank you
yes and if anyone else if i mangle your
name which i
i tend to do please catch me before it
goes on for 15 years like representative
lekas did
yes thank you for correcting that tool
tony yeah i think um
i don't remember what happened 15 years
ago i suspect once or twice or maybe i'm
misremembering i
corrected it but usually i then give up
so and maybe i'm
i was remembering someone else so uh
apologize for not doing it earlier
actually while we're on that topic
um uh i won't try the last name but
um matthew if you could say your name
because i'm not certain how to say it
okay please yeah to be honest uh to be
honest i don't even know if i know how
to say it since i'm a
third generation american at this point
but i've been saying uh
santa musta
we will all try to use that because no
matter if it's right or wrong for your
grandparents if that's the way you
you use it that's the way we should do
it exactly i totally agree
thanks again i will see you in the
morning i hope and
10 o'clock 10 o'clock right yeah
all right bye-bye everyone thank you
we'll see you next time